Hey guys, welcome to the show today. Hope you're feeling really good. I got a hat on. You guys don't. Are you jealous of my hat? I've got a microphone though. I'm ready to go with a microphone and a couple of headphones here. Let's see.
大家好，欢迎收听今天的节目。希望你们感觉都很好。我戴了一顶帽子。你们却没有。你们嫉妒我的帽子吗？不过我有麦克风。我准备好用麦克风和一副耳机了。让我看看。
That just leaves me and all I got is a really bad attitude. Oh no, and a bad speech thing. We're doing audio. Welcome to Smarter! Smarter! Oh boy. Smart. Less.
那就只剩我了，我有的只有一种非常糟糕的态度。哦不，还有一个糟糕的语音问题。我们在做音频。欢迎来到《聪明一点》（Smarter!）！《聪明一点》（Smarter!）！哦，天哪。《聪明少一点》（Smart Less）。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. You know, Sean, you look like, uh, you know, you look a little bit more blonde today. I know I got you do a rinse this morning. No, I got a haircut yesterday and I didn't color it. I got a color.
《聪明少一点》（Smart Less）。《聪明少一点》（Smart Less）。你知道，肖恩，你看起来，呃，你知道，你今天看起来金发多了一点。我知道我今天早上让你冲洗了一下。不，我昨天理发了，而且我没有染色。我染了色。
It's a little too dry. I saw Sean yesterday happened to be at CVS and he was buying, he bought three things of sun in. And he sprayed a bunch of sun in. It is a little lighter than normal and I don't like it. So I'm going to color it a little bit. Now is skevo going to get it? Sorry, go ahead, you go ahead. Sorry, yeah, because I, hang on a sec, Will,
它有点太干了。我昨天碰巧在CVS看到肖恩，他在买东西，他买了两三瓶Sun-in。然后他喷了很多Sun-in。它比平时浅了一点，我不喜欢。所以我打算稍微染一下。现在斯凯沃（Skevo）能明白吗？抱歉，你继续，你继续。抱歉，是的，因为我，等等，威尔，
this is important. What kind of color? I know, I want to get to skevo though. Skevo, the greatest name in all of hairdressing. Yeah. Sean, what is the color that one tries to target usually? Is there a name for it? A name for it. There's no name.
这很重要。什么颜色的？我知道，不过我想去找斯凯沃。斯凯沃，美发界最伟大的名字。是的。肖恩，人们通常试图以什么颜色为目标？它有一个名字吗？一个名字。没有名字。
Is it burnt sienna? No, it's like number five and number two or whatever they have, yeah. Oh, you blend, it's a blend. It's a blend, but I know you don't like when I color my hair, but I like it. Well, I like what you like, but I just want to make sure you know
是烧西恩娜红吗？不，就像五号和二号或者他们有的什么，是的。哦，你调和，这是一个混合。这是一个混合，但我知道你讨厌我染发，但我喜欢。好吧，我喜欢你喜欢的，但我只是想确保你知道
that I need no color to love you any more than I do. Well that's true, but. I'm at max. Yeah. I'm sorry. I'm still reeling. I can't believe you blend five and two. Yeah.
我不需要任何颜色来比现在更爱你。嗯，那是真的，但。我已经达到极限了。是的。对不起。我仍然感到震惊。我不敢相信你把五号和二号混合在一起。是的。
Honestly, I think the coloring world is gonna be, I'm gonna have to call Eli, our buddy Eli Thomas, Skeva, we should have a conference of all the hair guys we know. We'll get McMillan in there. Old sweet, sweet Chris. Chris McMillan. And we'll bring them all in.
老实说，我认为美发界将会，我得给我们的好朋友伊莱·托马斯、斯凯沃打电话，我们应该开个会，邀请我们认识的所有发型师。我们把麦克米兰（McMillan）也弄进去。老好人，甜心克里斯。克里斯·麦克米兰。我们把他们都请来。
Is Skevo short for anything? No, he is a shorter fellow, but no, his full name is Skevo. Do you call him anything for short? What would be short for Skevo? for anything? No, he is a shorter fellow, but no, his full name is Skevo. Do you call him anything for short? What would be short for Skevo? Hey, Skev. Oh, sometimes you drop the O, huh? Like if you're in a row.
斯凯沃是哪个名字的简称吗？不，他是个个头稍矮的家伙，不，他的全名就是斯凯沃。你叫他什么的简称吗？斯凯沃的简称会是什么？有任何简称吗？不，他是个个头稍矮的家伙，不，他的全名就是斯凯沃。你叫他什么的简称吗？斯凯沃的简称会是什么？嘿，斯凯夫（Skev）。哦，有时你把后面的“欧”去掉，对吧？就像你在连轴转的时候。
Yeah. If you're running a bunch of errands. What's his last name? Because usually the last name's more spicy than the first. I'm going to tell you right now, we can cut out this pause while I look it up. Please be Miller. His last name is Zambillas.
是的。如果你在跑很多腿。他姓什么？因为通常姓氏比名字更有意思。我现在就告诉你，我们可以剪掉这段我查阅时的停顿。千万别是米勒。他的姓是赞比拉斯（Zambillas）。
Zamboni. Zambillas. Would you say that you guys are tight? Super tight. Hey, Will, by the way, I played golf the other day with the guy whose grandmother, I believe I'm getting this right semi, right Invented the Zamboni. Oh, oh, I've played I've played golf with that guy, too
赞博尼（Zamboni）。赞比拉斯（Zambillas）。你会说你们俩关系很铁吗？超级铁。嘿，威尔，顺便说一下，前几天我和一个人打高尔夫球，他的祖母，我相信我没记错，半对吧，发明了赞博尼。哦，哦，我也和那家伙打过高尔夫。
Yeah, and it happened down here in like Paramount, California Surprisingly not in Canada. Yeah, and Tracy the Zamboni is the machine the little the sweet little car Or truck or minivan that you drive over the ice rinks to make it smooth and shiny. Cleans the ice, uses hot water and thing and then drags and smooths it out. It's the one thing for hockey that's heard it in terms of viewing because they have the ice between periods and therefore the intermissions are so long.
是的，这发生在加利福尼亚州派拉蒙之类的地方，令人惊讶的是不在加拿大。是的，特雷西，赞博尼就是那个机器，那个小巧可爱的小汽车或卡车或小型货车，你把它开过溜冰场，使其变得光滑发亮。清理冰面，用热水之类的东西，然后拖曳并将其弄平。这是冰球运动中在观看体验方面受到影响的一点，因为他们在两节之间有冰面清理，因此中场休息太长了。
It's been detrimental. It's 20 minutes and it's detrimental. There is no alternative. Why don't they get two out there? They do. They generally do. Pro games, they do, yeah. Maybe they need three.
这一直是有害的。有20分钟，这很有害。没有别的选择。他们为什么不在场上弄两个？他们会的。他们通常会。职业比赛，他们会的，是的。也许他们需要三个。
They might need three. I don't know. I was, you know, Michelle Pfeiffer. Oh wait, Sean's got something on this. Well, Michelle Pfeiffer's character's name in Grease 2 was Stephanie Zinoni. I always thought it was Zamboni. So listen.
他们可能需要三个。我不知道，我当时在想，米歇尔·菲佛。哦等等，肖恩对此有话要说。嗯，米歇尔·菲佛在《油脂2》（Grease 2）里的角色的名字叫斯蒂芬妮·齐诺尼（Stephanie Zinoni）。我一直以为是赞比尼（Zamboni）。所以听着。
Sorry, do you want to go down, do you have a list of stuff you misheard over the years? Okay, dudes, every once in a while, we get to have a guest on that is also our friend. Today is one of those days. I love every moment I spend with this woman and always wish for more. She's funny, but never on.
抱歉，你想顺便说说，你有一个多年来听错的东西的清单吗？好吧，伙计们，每隔一段时间，我们就会请一位同时也是我们朋友的嘉宾。今天是其中一天。我珍惜和这个女人在一起的每一刻，并且总是希望更多。她很搞笑，但从不刻意。
She's kind and warm, but never one of those smiley creeps. She's done movies, television, radio, podcasts, written and bestseller. She's been nominated for Emmys and Grammys. She's got two kids, one wife. She started in Mississippi and now she's right here. Say good morning to the great Tig Notaro. Tig!
她善良而温暖，但绝不是那种满脸堆笑的令人毛骨悚然的人。她拍过电影、电视、广播、播客，写过畅销书。她曾获得艾美奖和格莱美奖提名。她有两个孩子，一个妻子。她从密西西比开始，现在她就在这里。向伟大的蒂格·诺塔罗（Tig Notaro）问好。蒂格！
Oh, Tig! Tig! Tig Notaro. There, Tig. Tig. Tig Notaro. There she is. Oh. I love that I was described to a T and Sean's still like, who could this possibly be? Yeah, I had to zip through it.
哦，蒂格！蒂格！蒂格·诺塔罗。来吧，蒂格。蒂格。蒂格·诺塔罗。她在这儿。哦。我喜欢我被描述得淋漓尽致，而肖恩仍然像是在想，这到底会是谁？是的，我不得不快速浏览一下。
This doesn't even sound remotely familiar. I knew, and I knew, and I didn't say anything because I didn't want my disappointment to come through the microphone so early. How dare you? And not even disappointment, outrage. Now, hey Tig. Tig, your hair is growing out, it looks good.
这听起来甚至一点也不耳熟。我知道，我知道，我什么也没说，因为我不想让我的失望这么早就通过麦克风传达出来。你怎么敢？甚至都不是失望，是愤怒。现在，嘿，蒂格。蒂格，你的头发在变长，看起来不错。
Oh, I just started today, I'm surprised you noticed. No way has it grown out. Yeah, you really pushed hard for that. You pushed it out. I just started growing it out today. I woke up and I was like, you know what, I'm going to grow my hair out. And I can't believe you noticed.
哦，我今天刚开始留，我很惊讶你注意到了。它怎么可能已经长长了。是的，你真的很努力地推动它生长。你把它推出来了。我今天才开始留长发。我醒来后就想，你知道吗，我要把头发留长。我真不敢相信你注意到了。
Day one, please do one of those things where you take a snapshot every day for 365 and then put it together as a video and set it to a really sad song. Okay. Hey Tig, speaking of sad songs, both your parents still with us? All three are dead.
第一天，请做那种每天拍一张快照连续365天，然后把它剪辑成视频并配上一首非常悲伤的歌的事情。好的。嘿，蒂格，说到悲伤的歌，你父母都还在世吗？三个都去世了。
Three? Three. Well I had a stepfather that raised me. Okay. And in fact, not only is he dead, but... He's not coming back. He's not coming back. He is not, he has no way back to town.
三个？三个。嗯，我有一个抚养我长大的继父。好的。事实上，不仅他死了，而且……他回不来了。他回不来了。他不会，他没有办法回城了。
Couple of years ago when he died, and we were having his funeral in Mississippi, it was an outdoor burial. And we were talking to the priest was saying, how do you want to do this? It's more casual outside. I said, well, I was going to say something. And my brother said, well, I'll go first.
几年前他去世时，我们在密西西比为他举行葬礼，那是露天土葬。我们在跟牧师说话，牧师说，你们想怎么做？在外面比较随意。我说，嗯，我要说几句。我哥哥说，好吧，我先来。
I'll just say something really quick. And he walks up and he fell into a grave. No. No. No. What? Yes he did. What, is that true? Is it?
我就随便说几句。然后他走过去，掉进了一个坟墓里。不会吧。不会吧。不会吧。什么？是的，他掉了进去。什么，那是真的吗？真的吗？
It is very true. And my entire family is sitting there and you see everyone just go, oh shit, oh my God. And my brother, and there's like this tarp over the hole and you just see my brother slowly, like it caught him a little bit, but he's slowly going down and yeah. I mean that would be overwritten in a comedy.
千真万确。我全家人都坐在那里，你看到每个人都说，哦，操，哦天哪。然后我哥哥，洞上有一块类似防水布的东西，然后你看到我哥哥慢慢地，就像它稍微勾住他一下，但他慢慢地往下掉，是的。我的意思是，这在喜剧里都会被删掉。
I know, it's too much and we're trying to help him out. Had he had a few? Had he had a few? No, no, it was no. He's just blind. No, the place messed up. They were supposed to put plywood over it and you see the people from the...
我知道，这太夸张了，我们在试图把他拉出来。他喝了几杯吗？他喝了几杯吗？不，不，不是的。他只是眼瞎。不，是场地搞砸了。他们本该在上面铺上合板，然后你看到来自……
I love that the lawsuit says, the place messed up. We're suing you because you messed up. That's the legal terminology. We messed up, we messed up. What was the effort like getting him out? Was it tough to get him out? Well, we were like, oh my gosh, trying to help him out.
我喜欢这种诉讼的说法，场地搞砸了。我们起诉你们是因为你们搞砸了。这就是法律术语。我们搞砸了，我们搞砸了。把他弄出来的过程是怎样的？把他弄出来很难吗？嗯，我们当时想，哦天哪，试图把他拉出来。
He's like, no, no, no, I'm okay. And he's pulling himself out like the night of the living dead, like with his dirty suit, just grabbing dirt and grass, trying to pull himself out of the hole. Like he was not going to let anybody pull him out. Have you ever had a nightmare with that? Has that imagery ever come back to you, like sort of? No, that was like a dream come true. That was a nightmare.
他却说，不，不，不，我没事。他像《活死人黎明》里那样把自己从洞里拽出来，穿着脏兮兮的西装，抓着泥土和草，试图把自己从洞里拉出来。好像他绝不让任何人把他拉出来。你做过关于那个的噩梦吗？那种画面有没有重新回到你的脑海里，类似那种？不，那就像梦想成真。那是一场噩梦。
That was like, oh my God, I couldn't believe my stepfather did not get to see that happen. Right. You couldn't believe your luck that you got to witness it too. Well, and immediately I thought, oh my God, this must happen all the time. And then I was like, wait, this can't happen all the time. In Mississippi is the end of that sentence. In Mississippi is the end of that sentence. all the time. And then I was like, wait, this can't happen all the time. It's falling to graves.
那就像是，哦天哪，我简直不敢相信我的继父没有看到那一幕发生。对吧。你简直不敢相信自己的运气，你竟然也能目睹这一幕。嗯，我立刻想，哦天哪，这一定经常发生。然后我想，等等，这不可能经常发生。在密西西比是这句话的结尾。在密西西比是这句话的结尾。经常发生。然后我想，等等，这不可能经常发生。掉进坟墓里。
In Mississippi is the end of that sentence. And people ask, they're like, oh, how come, what's it with all of these stories from the South and Mississippi? And I'm like, I have no idea, but I truly just show up, look around and head home with stories like that. I really. What about, is that, did you,
在密西西比是这句话的结尾。人们会问，他们会说，哦，怎么回事，南方和密西西比的这些故事都是怎么回事？我就说，我完全不知道，但我真的只是出现，四处看看，然后带着这样的故事回家。我真的。话说，那是，你，
was Army of the Dead about zombies? You did an Army of the Dead. Ooh, good transition. Army of the Dead, I did do Army of the Dead, yeah. In fact, I did it on green screen. Right, because famously, you replaced a fella on that, right? And so you had to shoot everything on green screen Right, because famously you replaced a fella on that, right? And so you had to shoot everything on green screen and then they superimposed you into a film
《活死人大军》（Army of the Dead）是关于僵尸的吗？你拍了《活死人大军》。哦，好过渡。《活死人大军》，我确实拍了《活死人大军》，是的。事实上，我是在绿幕前拍的。对，因为众所周知，你在里面代替了一个家伙，对吧？所以你必须在绿幕前拍摄所有镜头，对吧，因为众所周知你代替了一个家伙，对吧？所以你必须在绿幕前拍摄所有镜头然后他们把你超级叠加到一部
that was already shot, correct? Yeah, easy enough. Were there zombies in it? There were, there were zombies. So were you like, ah, ah, but nothing was there? Oh. Sean, you saw the movie, I guess. Clearly read for it, did not get it, I've done some green screen acting.
已经拍好的电影里，对吧？对，很简单。里面有僵尸吗？有，有僵尸。所以你当时是不是想，啊，啊，但周围什么都没有？哦。肖恩，我想你看过这部电影。显然试镜过，但没选上，我演过一些绿幕戏。
I've done some green screen acting. Yeah. Yeah, I had to, I flew the escape, like the helicopter to... Get in! Yeah. I've got to take off. And I had to, that's not my typical, you know,
我演过一些绿幕戏。是的。是的，我不得不，我驾驶逃生舱，就像直升机去……进来！是的。我得起飞了。我不得不，那不是我典型的，你知道的，
acting role where I'm yelling things and fighting things and had to do it all on green screen. And just literally like three feet away is craft service. Just three feet away. Yeah, through every scene you see me grabbing a donut and it's all on camera. But you weren't a zombie yourself. You didn't have to get into any zombie makeup, did you? No, I was just, I think a lesbian.
我大喊大叫、打打杀杀的表演角色，我必须在绿幕前完成这一切。而且字面意义上，离我只有三英尺远就是剧组餐饮区。只有三英尺远。是的，在每一个镜头里你都能看到我抓着一个甜甜圈，而且全被拍进镜头里了。但你自己不是僵尸。你不需要化任何僵尸妆，对吧？不，我只是，我想是个女同性恋。
Those zombies aren't flying helicopters. It's just a lesbian flying a helicopter. That's what you said? Yeah. I think that's what I am and everything. No take. Now what about in Star Trek? I'm a lesbian in space.
那些僵尸可不会开直升机。那只是一个女同性恋在开直升机。你是这么说的吗？是的。我想我就是那个身份，而且应有尽有。没有NG。现在，在《星际迷航》（Star Trek）里呢？我是太空中的女同性恋。
There's lesbians in space? There are now. There are? Yeah. Now, do you have to wear any alien makeup in Star Trek? No, no. In fact, they barely put any makeup on me, I think because they really wanna
太空中也有女同性恋？现在有了。真的吗？是的。现在，你在《星际迷航》里需要戴什么外星人妆吗？不，不。事实上，他们几乎没怎么给我化妆，我想是因为他们真的很想
know that I'm a lesbian. What if they just put jobs of lipstick and like really make me that? Big eyelashes. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Or you're just sexually active. I have massive cleavage too. No, truly? No. No, no. My tits are in a dumpster.
让我知道我是一个女同性恋。如果他们只是涂抹口红然后真的把我弄成那样呢？大睫毛。是的，是的，是的。或者你只是性生活活跃。我还有巨大的乳沟。真的吗？没有。不，不。我的奶子在垃圾桶里。
In Hollywood. Isn't that the title of your new special? Yeah. All right, hey Tig, let's go back to the very beginning. All right, so we're in Mississippi. All right, we're in Mississippi. Everyone's alive. Everybody's alive, everybody's happy. It's a we're in Mississippi. Everyone's alive. Everybody's alive. Everybody's
在好莱坞。这难道不是你的新专场的名字吗？是的。好吧，嘿，蒂格，让我们回到最初的起点。好吧，所以我们在密西西比。好吧，我们在密西西比。每个人都活着。每个人都活着，每个人都很开心。这是一个我们在密西西比。每个人都活着。每个人都活着。每个人都
happy. Good way to start. Now, but you did start as a rock band manager type of promoter. I'll help you get on stage and from city to city type of person. Yes. Yes. Yes, that's true. Dude, have you ever spoken English before? What the fuck is going on? I'm such a journalist. But, you know, I do love that about our show. Every once in a while, as I said in the intro, we get a friend on here, and I end up learning so much more about them
很开心。很好的开始方式。不过，你确实是以摇滚乐队经纪人兼某种推广人的身份开始的。我帮你上台，从一个城市到另一个城市的那种人。是的。是的，没错。老兄，你以前说过英语吗？这到底是怎么回事？我真像个记者。不过，你知道，我确实很喜欢我们节目这一点。正如我在开场白中所说，每隔一段时间，我们就会请一位朋友来这里，而我最终对他们了解的
than I've ever learned in our personal lives. And why do you think that is? Because you don't take time to ask. I don't ask questions. I was going to sidebar for a second. You don't ask questions about other people, right? Hey, Wayne, keep it quiet. So, Wayne.
比我在我们个人生活中了解到的要多得多。你觉得这是为什么？因为你没有花时间去问。我不问问题。我刚才想顺便说一句。你不会问关于别人的问题，对吧？嘿，韦恩，安静点。所以，韦恩。
You know what I mean? So, but what about this? So you managed bands? Well, I really love music. And I play a little guitar, a little drums. Drums, yeah, I read that, I read that. And you're a lesbian, you said, just to bring back. And I'm a lesbian, so.
你知道我的意思吗？所以，但是这个呢？所以你管理乐队？嗯，我真的很喜欢音乐。我弹一点吉他，打一点鼓。鼓，是的，我读过，我读过。你是个女同性恋，你刚才说了，为了重申一下。我是个女同性恋，所以。
Oh, just a little bit, sorry, I got confused. And these are drums with sticks, not the hand drums. No, no, no, no, no, no. That's, see, I'm still dabbling as a lesbian, so I'm playing actual drums. Once you cross over, then you start doing drum circles. and so I'm playing actual drums. Once you cross over, then you start doing drum circles. I've been dabbling for decades, not sold on it.
哦，只是一点点，抱歉，我搞糊涂了。这些是用鼓棒敲的鼓，不是手鼓。不，不，不，不，不，不。那是，看，我还在作为女同性恋浅尝辄止，所以我打的是真正的鼓。一旦你跨过那一步，你就会开始参加鼓圈活动。所以我打的是真正的鼓。一旦你跨过那一步，你就会开始参加鼓圈活动。我浅尝辄止了几十年，还没完全接受。
I was too shy to perform. I tried and it was nerve wracking. My first girlfriend played in in a band and so I just started booking the band and working in music. And the music. How long was that you did that? I don't know, maybe three years. And are we driving around in a van? Are we, yeah.
我太害羞了，不敢表演。我尝试过，那太让人伤脑筋了。我的第一任女朋友在一个乐队里，所以我开始为那个乐队预订演出并在音乐界工作。那个音乐。你做那个多久了？不知道，大概三年吧。我们是在面包车里到处开吗？我们是，是的。
Yeah, yeah. Wow. Like we went on tour in a van, you mean like that? Yeah. Like we were touring, yeah, we were in a van. One time we actually rented a friend of ours, Bronco, and while we were on tour, the hood flew up and like bent in half.
是的，是的。哇。就像我们乘面包车去巡演，你是这个意思吗？是的。就像我们在巡演，是的，我们在面包车里。有一次我们实际上租了一辆我们朋友的野马（Bronco），当我们在巡演时，引擎盖飞了起来，对折了。
And we couldn't see anything. We couldn't see anything. My God, that's my worst nightmare. I literally thought about that just the other day. I was watching, I could have sworn the hood was vibrating a little bit. I thought, what if this thing flies up there? It's like a Blanchett V. Chase one.
而且我们什么也看不见。我们什么也看不见。天哪，那是我的噩梦。我前几天才刚想到这个。我当时在看着，我发誓引擎盖在稍微振动。我想，如果这玩意儿飞起来会怎么样？就像凯特·布兰切特追逐的那种。
What the hood of the, like an SUV type of thing? A Bronco. Yeah, but it was like an old Bronco. And so if the top goes off, why can't you see? Because there's still a windshield. Because you're- The hood. The hood, the hood, sorry, sorry. I thought you meant the roof of the car.
像SUV那样的车的引擎盖？一辆野马。是的，但那是一辆老款野马。所以如果车顶拿掉了，为什么你看不见？因为还有挡风玻璃。因为你——引擎盖。引擎盖，引擎盖，抱歉，抱歉。我以为你指的是车顶。
Are you catching every third word? I'm actually about every fourth word. So now, but Tic. What kind of music was the band or the bands that you did? You know, I mean, folk rock. Yeah, of course, of course. Hey, so, but now, but you decided to help this band out because you wanted to have a seat that was less exposed to the spotlight.
你是不是每三个词就漏掉一个？我实际上大概漏掉每四个词。那么现在，但是蒂格。那个乐队或那些乐队是什么风格的音乐？你知道，我的意思是，民谣摇滚。是的，当然，当然。嘿，所以，但是现在，你决定帮这个乐队是因为你想找一个受聚光灯照射较少的位置。
But then while you're doing this, you said, well, hang on a second. Maybe I actually want to be upfront. I want to do stand up now where there's nothing between you and the audience. Yes. Well, I moved my very good friends that I grew up with that are still very close to me. We moved from Denver. We were living in Denver at the time.
但当你在做这个的时候，你却说，嗯，等一下。也许我其实想走到最前面。我现在想做单口喜剧，在那里你和观众之间没有任何东西。是的。嗯，我和我一起长大的好朋友们搬家了，我们至今关系依然非常密切。我们从丹佛搬走了。我们当时住在丹佛。
And we moved from Denver to LA and they moved there to pursue TV and film. And I was newly out of a relationship and I was like out of a relationship, and I was like, well, I guess I'll just go with you. And so I went, and then when I got there, I saw in the LA Weekly all of the different opportunities to do stand-up, which had been my top secret dream.
我们从丹佛搬到了洛杉矶，他们搬到那里是为了追求电视和电影事业。我刚刚结束了一段恋情，我当时想，结束了一段恋情，我当时想，好吧，我想我就跟你一起去吧。于是我去了，当我到了那里后，我在《洛杉矶周刊》（LA Weekly）上看到了做单口喜剧的各种机会，这一直是我最高机密的梦想。
How about that? Even though you were shy. Even though I was shy. And so I spent the first two weeks going to every open mic I could possibly go to and then I how nerve-wracking I'm getting nervous. Just thinking about it. What was that first? Don't worry. It all works out. Okay, I end up on smartless. Yeah Now wait, would you would you would you just like climb into a bottom of a bottle before you got up there? Like how did you get over this initial stage fright and get up there and start doing it?
觉得怎么样？尽管你很害羞。尽管我很害羞。所以我花了两周时间去了我能去的每一个开放麦，然后我——多让人伤脑筋啊，我开始紧张了。光是想想。那第一次……别担心。一切都会顺利的。好吧，我最后上了《聪明少 Less》。是的。现在等等，你会不会，你会不会在登台前先喝个烂醉？你是怎么克服这种最初的舞台恐惧并上台开始表演的？
Well somebody had canceled at the show that I was watching and I asked the person, which is so, I should dig this footage up. I have footage of myself talking into a flashlight in a mirror, working out material in my studio apartment. I didn't have footage of myself talking into a flashlight in a mirror, working out material in my studio apartment. Amazing. For those two weeks. Amazing. And so I was practicing in the mirror with my flashlight.
嗯，我在看的那个演出里有人取消了，我问那个人，这太，我应该把这段录像找出来。我有自己对着工作室公寓里一面镜子里的手电筒说话的录像，在排练素材。我没有自己对着工作室公寓里一面镜子里的手电筒说话的录像，在排练素材。太神奇了。在那两周里。太神奇了。所以我一直在对着手电筒在镜子里练习。
All you had to do is flip it on, you could tell ghost stories right after. Exactly. And so I had all of this stuff worked out over those two weeks that I had been living in LA, and then I asked the person, I was like, hey, can I go on stage? And she was like, sure, and so I did.
你所要做的就是把它打开，你马上就可以讲鬼故事了。没错。所以我在住在洛杉矶的那两周里把所有这些东西都排练好了，然后我问那个人，我说，嘿，我能上台吗？她就说，当然可以，于是我上了。
And when I say it went well, if you showed me the footage now. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It would be horrifying. Really? Really? But Tig, what was the first thing you said? Okay, the very first thing is a true story. My friend who I rented the Bronco from. Yeah, who's mad at you because of the.
当我说进展顺利时，如果你现在让我看录像。是的，是的，是的。那会很可怕。真的吗？真的吗？但蒂格，你说的第一句话是什么？好吧，第一句话是一个真实的故事。我从他那里租了野马的朋友。是的，那个生你气的人因为……
Returned it without a hood, yeah. We moved beyond that, we got the car fixed and remained friends. So my friend, his name was Ro. Hey Ro. Well he passed away sadly. Oh, sorry. Everyone's dead.
把车还回来时没有引擎盖，是的。我们已经翻过那一页了，我们把车修好了，依然是朋友。所以我的朋友，他叫罗（Ro）。嘿，罗。嗯，他不幸去世了。哦，抱歉。大家都死了。
Anyway, Ro called me and told me our mutual friend Johnny was gonna be in Denver. Can we say hi to Johnny? Johnny's still with us? I don't know where Johnny is. Say hi to Johnny. Hi Johnny. Hey Johnny.
总之，罗打电话告诉我，我们的共同朋友约翰尼（Johnny）要在丹佛。我们能跟约翰尼打个招呼吗？约翰尼还在世吗？我不知道约翰尼在哪里。向约翰尼打个招呼。嗨，约翰尼。嘿，约翰尼。
Johnny. So he told me that our mutual friend was gonna be in town when I was living in Denver. He said Johnny's band is gonna be there. You should go see him. And he hooked me up with the road manager for me to get tickets to Johnny's show. This is some backstory.
约翰尼。所以他告诉我，当我住在丹佛时，我们的共同朋友要进城。他说约翰尼的乐队要在那儿。你应该去看他。他帮我联系了巡演经理，让我拿到了约翰尼演出的门票。这是些背景故事。
Yeah, yeah, I'm enjoying it. I'll say, I'll say. And, oh, there's more. Okay. And so, I called Johnny's road manager. What was the number? This is where the story kicks in. Okay.
是的，是的，我很享受。我得说，我得说。哦，还有呢。好吧。所以，我给约翰尼的巡演经理打电话。号码是多少？故事就是从这里开始的。好的。
So I called the road manager, and I said, Johnny's friend, could I get tickets to the show? And he said, yes. And then at the end of the conversation, he says, now I don't feel comfortable calling you this, but I guess I'll see you tonight, pig. And I said, oh, I said,
所以我给巡演经理打电话，我说，我是约翰尼的朋友，我能拿到演出门票吗？他说，可以。然后在对话结束时，他说，现在我叫你这个名字可能觉得不太舒服，不过我想我今晚会见到你的，猪（Pig）。我说，哦，我说，
I actually don't feel comfortable calling you, or with you calling me pig either. I said, my name is actually Tig. And he said, yeah, that's what I said, Pig. And I said, no, it's Tig with a T. And he said, Tit? And then I just said, yeah, that's right, it's Pig Tit. I'll see you tonight.
我其实也觉得叫你这个名字，或者让你叫我这个名字不太舒服。我说，我的名字其实是蒂格（Tig）。他说，是的，我就是这么说的，猪（Pig）。我说，不，是用T开头的蒂格（Tig）。他说，乳头（Tit）？然后我就说，对，没错，是猪乳头（Pig Tit）。今晚见。
So anyway, that was my first story. No way. That must have killed. Now, your name Tig was given to you by your brother when you were two years old. Yeah. See, guys, I know how to research shit. Yeah.
总之，那是我的第一个故事。不会吧。那肯定笑翻全场了。现在，你的名字蒂格是你两岁时你哥哥给你的。是的。看，伙计们，我知道怎么做调查。是的。
Well, it's more fun to just ask her how she got it and then she tells us that rather, you know what I mean? Oh, fuck. Wait. Fuck you. We can do it. Are we still rolling? We do it a few different ways and then just see which.
嗯，直接问她名字是怎么来的，然后她告诉我们，比这个更有趣，你知道我的意思吗？哦，操。等等。操你。我们可以做到的。我们还在录吗？我们用几种不同的方式做，然后看看哪个。
Let's just pick one. Why are you sweating, baby? What is going on? Okay. He loves me. He's nervous. So, but your real name, I think, is one of the best names in the history of names. I've known you for 75,000 years, I don't even know your real name. We can say it, it's on Wikipedia.
我们就挑一个吧。宝贝，你为什么在流汗？这到底是怎么回事？好吧。他爱我。他很紧张。所以，不过你的真名，我认为是名字历史上最好的名字之一。我认识你七万五千年了，我甚至不知道你的真名。我们可以说出来，维基百科上有。
I don't even know if you'd pronounce it correctly. I know what you think it is. Oh, well then, that's a good hint. Well, let's hear that. Let's hear what he thinks it is. Can I guess the correct pronunciation? Yes. Matilfte. That's correct.
我甚至不知道你能不能正确发音。我知道你认为它是什么。哦，那是个很好的提示。好吧，让我们听听。听听他是怎么想的。我能猜出正确的发音吗？是的。Matilfte。猜对了。
Matilfte. No, it's Matil. Oh. Matil. Well then what happens to the D? M-A-T-H-I-L-L-E. Is it French? M-A-T-H-I-L-D-E, but it's pronounced Matil.
Matilfte。不，是Matil。哦。Matil。那字母D去哪儿了？M-A-T-H-I-L-L-E。是法语吗？M-A-T-H-I-L-D-E，但发音是Matil。
Matil, so you don't suggest, the D-E is, no, there's no use of that. That's French Creole, yes? I think it's just French. French. My mother was Matil, my grandmother was Matil, my grandmother went by Teal, my mother went by Suzy, and I go by Tig.
Matil，所以你不建议，D-E是，不，没有那个发音。那是法式克里奥尔语，对吧？我想它只是法语。法语。我母亲叫Matil，我祖母叫Matil，我祖母平时叫Teal，我母亲平时叫Suzy，我叫Tig。
Wow. And then why did your young brother come up with Tig? He was older than me. He couldn't pronounce Tig, or he couldn't pronounce Matil, and somehow he came up with Tig, and so. And his name is Rod. Renault. Renault.
哇。那为什么你年幼的哥哥想出了蒂格这个名字？他比我大。他不会发蒂格的音，或者他不会发Matil的音，不知怎么的他就想出了蒂格，所以。他的名字叫罗德（Rod）。雷诺（Renault）。
Is R-E-N-A-U-L-T, Renault? R-E-N-A-U-D. A-U-D, Renault. Renault. Wait, who was French-A-U-D. A-U-D, Renault, Renault. Wait, who was French? Do people speak French? My mother. Is Renault still with us?
是R-E-N-A-U-L-T，雷诺？R-E-N-A-U-D。A-U-D，雷诺。雷诺。等等，谁是法裔-A-U-D。A-U-D，雷诺，雷诺。等等，谁是法国人？有人说法语吗？我母亲。雷诺还在世吗？
Yes, he's the one that fell in the grave and left. Oh, he's the one that went, Renault, let's just shout out to Renault, sava, Renault. Yeah, Renault. One cigarette. One baguette. And we will be right back.
是的，他就是那个掉进坟墓里然后离开的人。哦，他就是那个去，雷诺，让我们向雷诺致敬，萨瓦（sava），雷诺。是的，雷诺。一根烟。一个法棍。我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show. Wait, I wanna know, like, back to the standup, and that was a really funny story. Did you know, because when I did- Thank you. You're welcome. Oh, Jesus. Was there-
现在，回到节目中。等等，我想知道，就像，回到单口喜剧，那是个非常搞笑的故事。你知道吗，因为当我做——谢谢。不客气。哦，天哪。有没有——
If I take it, come on. You don't do that. We'll stay out of this, okay? Oh, God. Was there, come on. You don't do that. We'll stay out of this, okay? Oh God. Was there, did you know, cause when I first did it I was terrible. This is where we take a break, sorry. You did stand up?
如果我接受它，来吧。你不能那样做。我们不管这事了，好吧？哦，天哪。有没有，来吧。你不能那样做。我们不管这事了，好吧？哦天哪。有没有，你知道吗，因为我第一次做的时候我太糟糕了。我们该休息一下了，抱歉。你做过单口喜剧？
Hang on, this is Tig, we always do this where we take a break. Sean, and why don't you just tell, our audience knows, but tell Tig what your first joke was. Let's go ahead. Well, I think. It's not pig tit, is it?
等等，这是蒂格，我们总是这样，我们要休息一下。肖恩，你为什么不直接告诉，我们的观众知道，但告诉蒂格你的第一个笑话是什么？我们继续吧。嗯，我想。不是猪乳头吧？
It's a callback, you know. My first joke was, well, I'll do two, because one's not even, one was they say ballet is one of the most difficult things you could do, so just don't do it. That was the first one. And then the second one was- Wait, I'm sorry, that was the joke?
这是一个包袱，你知道的。我的第一个笑话是，嗯，我要讲两个，因为一个甚至不算，一个是他们说芭蕾舞是你所能做的最困难的事情之一，所以就别去做了。那是第一个。然后第二个是——等等，抱歉，那就是个笑话？
There was a joke. Yeah. Wait, say it again, that was the joke? There was a joke. Yeah. Wait, I thought, say it again? You're with it, you're on it, you're right on it. They say doing ballet is one of the most difficult things you could do, so I say just don't do it. And then the second one was... What was the second part of your speech?
那是个笑话。是的。等等，再说一遍，那就是个笑话？那是个笑话。是的。等等，我想，再说一遍？你懂的，你很在行，你完全懂。他们说跳芭蕾舞是你所能做的最困难的事情之一，所以我说那就别去做了。然后第二个是什么——你演讲的第二部分是什么？
Appropriate joke, appropriate response. And then the second one was really bad. There's not even a joke. Wait a second. It got worse. I can't. Go ahead with the second one, Sean. Because I didn't know how to.
恰当的笑话，恰当的反应。然后第二个真的很糟糕。甚至连个笑话都算不上。等一下。更糟糕了。我不能。说第二个吧，肖恩。因为我不知道怎么……
Now you've got the audience. Guys, he's on a roll, let him go. And then what? He had the audience with that first one, and you finished off. I didn't know how to write a joke. What was your closer? My closer?
现在你吸引了观众。伙计们，他正顺风顺水，让他说。然后呢？他用第一个笑话抓住了观众，然后你收尾了。我不知道怎么写笑话。你的收尾是什么？我的收尾？
My closer was something like, hey, isn't it funny when you see people outside in public call their pet for the first time? Like, you know, hey Spot, hey whatever. But like, what if it's like, hey Mustard, come here. Hey Ketchup. And it was, there's not even a joke. It's just bad.
我的收尾类似于，嘿，当你看到人们在公共场合第一次叫他们的宠物时，不是很搞笑吗？就像，你知道，嘿，小点（Spot），嘿，随便什么。但是，如果像是，嘿，芥末酱（Mustard），过来。嘿，番茄酱（Ketchup）。这根本不是个笑话。这太糟了。
But at 22 years old, I'm like, this is gonna kill. And it was, I mean, I don't even know what the joke is. It's honestly it's mystifying Yeah, that's somebody would just have that not just have the balls to get up and do it We know how scary that is. I'm not a stand-up neither Yeah, but then be that bad but to go but to go up and and think think right that you just talk would be an Appropriate thing to say in front of open with that as a comedy, just to say out loud as a thought. And to relay that in front of someone who would... Take, you had the number one selling comedy album in the world in 2013.
但在22岁的时候，我心想，这绝对会火。然而，我的意思是，我甚至不知道笑话是什么。老实说，这太令人费解了。是的，居然有人有这种胆量上台去演。我们知道那有多可怕。我也不是演单口喜剧的，是的。但却能烂到那种程度，还能上台去，而且自以为是，认为这在前面作为开场白是一个恰当的笑话，只是大声说出来作为一个想法。并在一个会……接受的人面前复述出来，你在2013年拥有全球销量第一的喜剧专辑。
Yeah, number one. Even without Sean writing my material. Jake, is there a way... Is there any way you could make Sean's, either of Sean's, and I'm gonna use the term joke loosely, would you ever be able to make that work on stage? Do you think that that's? Change the name of the animal from mustard or ketchup
是的，第一名。甚至不需要肖恩帮我写素材。杰克，有没有办法……有没有办法你能把肖恩的，肖恩的任何一个，我姑且用“笑话”这个词，你有没有可能在舞台上把那个效果做出来？你觉得那行得通吗？把动物的名字从芥末酱或番茄酱
to something that would be a little bit funnier to hear yelled across a park. Or just construct a joke about it, which was my question, which was I was getting at, which was like, when you got up, because you're a very great storyteller, and a lot of your comedy comes from things that have happened to you in life.
改成在公园里隔空大喊时听起来更有趣的名字。或者围绕它构建一个笑话，这就是我的问题，也就是我一直想切入的，那就是，当你上台时，因为你是一个非常优秀的讲故事的人，而你的很多喜剧都来自于生活中发生在你身上的事情。
Thank you. You're welcome. Fuckin' hell. Honest to fucking God, David. How did you learn how to craft the rhythm of a joke or a story, because I got, the point of me telling you how bad I was, I got up and thought I could just talk.
谢谢。不客气。真他妈的。老实说，大卫。你是如何学会掌握笑话或故事的节奏的，因为我——我向你讲述我有多糟糕的意义在于，我上台了，以为自己只要随便说说话就行。
And were you that way when you first started, or did you know how to write? Well, I thought, and I realized, I must be like everybody else, that you go watch stand-up and you think, oh my God, I can do this. Everybody that does stand-up thinks, oh my God. And you know, I get calls from people that are like,
你刚开始的时候也是这样吗，还是说你知道怎么写作？嗯，我当时想，我意识到，我一定和所有人一样，你去看单口喜剧，然后你心想，哦天哪，我能做到这一点。每一个演单口喜剧的人都心想，哦天哪。你知道的，我接到过一些人的电话，他们说，
oh, my friend at work is so funny, he's moving to LA, can you meet with him? It's like, yeah, everybody in the office is hilarious, everybody watching standup thinks they can do it. And it just was, you know, I took the leap like everybody else and I think my first one did go well and then I signed up for a competition the second time I did stand up,
哦，我单位的朋友太搞笑了，他要搬到洛杉矶去，你能跟他见个面吗？这就好像是，是的，办公室里的每个人都很搞笑，每个看单口喜剧的人都觉得自己能行。这只是，你知道的，我像其他人一样迈出了这一步，而且我觉得我的第一次确实进行得很顺利，然后我在第二次演单口喜剧时报名参加了一个比赛，
and I bombed so hard. And the only thing I heard in the audience, aside from silence, was my friend Derek choking to death laughing at me. And then I ran off stage, and we drove back from Orange County back to LA. But it's just been a process of, you know, of, I mean, I thought I could do it.
结果我惨败。除了死一般的寂静之外，我在观众席上听到的唯一声音，就是我的朋友德里克（Derek）笑得快要窒息了。然后我跑下台，我们从奥兰治县（Orange County）开车回洛杉矶。但这只是一个过程，你知道的，我的意思是，我以为我能行。
I have been doing it. And, you know, I started out doing kind of deadpan one-liners and then they kind of got longer. And I experimented. Will, I'm talking. No, I was going to tell you something, I know. We always interrupt. This is our hallmark of our show is interrupting our guests.
我一直都在做这个。而且，你知道的，我一开始是做那种面无表情的单行笑话，然后它们变长了。我进行了尝试。威尔，我在说话。不，我本来想告诉你一些事的，我知道。我们总是打断别人。这是我们节目打断嘉宾的招牌特色。
So then once I was finally, no, go ahead, Will. Well, I just wanted to say what I was kind of agreeing, I wanted to say that it's not surprising and kind of going off what Sean said, it's not surprising because you have one of those, you are the type of person, and I don't know you that well, but we've known each other over the years a little bit and gotten to know each other a little bit more.
所以当我终于，不，你继续，威尔。嗯，我只是想说我刚才挺赞同的，我想说这并不令人意外，顺着肖恩的话说，这并不令人意外，因为你拥有那种——你是那种类型的人，虽然我不是很了解你，但我们这些年来多少认识了一点，也彼此更加了解了。
You are a very funny person. And it's not true for all standups. And you're not just a standup, but you are a very naturally funny person. You don't have a choice in it. I will say that. Like, I don't think that- Thank you.
你是一个非常有趣的人。对所有单口喜剧演员来说并非如此。你不仅仅是一个单口喜剧演员，你是一个天生非常有趣的人。你对此别无选择。我得这么说。就像，我不认为——谢谢。
Thank you. Fuck, no, sorry, Sean gets that one. And you are a very naturally, so I think that it does come, I'm not surprised that the first time you went up, that you were able to sort of connect with the audience because you're a very naturally funny person. I will say that. That's what I wanted to say.
谢谢。操，不，抱歉，肖恩拿那个。你是一个天生非常有趣的人，所以我觉得这确实顺理成章，你第一次上台时能够和观众建立某种联系，我并不感到意外，因为你是一个天生非常有趣的人。我只想说这个。这就是我想说的。
Well, I appreciate that. Well, and certainly after I thought I had gotten my bearings in stand-up, I thought, well, I've got this, and I booked my first gig on the road, and it was like in this comedy club in a strip mall, and I had only done shows in Los Angeles in like kind of hip rooms and whatever. And then now I'm like in the middle of nowhere strip mall and I was staying with friends
嗯，我很感激。嗯，当然在我以为自己已经掌握了单口喜剧的门窍之后，我想，好吧，我懂了，我预订了我的第一场巡演演出，那是在一个露天购物中心的一家喜剧俱乐部里，我以前只在洛杉矶那种很时髦的场地之类的演出。然后现在我身处鸟不拉屎的购物中心，我当时借住在朋友家
and they let me use their car. But the venue actually will put you up at a condo and they have a car for comedians. And I was like, oh, I don't need the car, but thanks. And this club was called Wits End in Denver. Oh, that's good. And I bombed, this is my first road gig, I bombed the entire weekend.
他们让我用他们的车。但场地其实会为你安排一间公寓，他们为喜剧演员准备了一辆车。当时我想，哦，我不需要车，但谢谢了。这家俱乐部叫丹佛的“尽头”（Wits End）。哦，那挺好的。我砸了，这是我的第一场巡演演出，我整个周末都砸了。
And then I hear before the second show on Friday or Saturday, I hear the owner saying, where is our emergency fill-in comedian? And I was thinking, oh no, what happened to Nancy? Because I was thinking something must have happened. I was mortified. I thought she died. And he was like,
然后在周五或周六的第二场演出之前，我听到老板说，我们的紧急替补喜剧演员在哪里？我当时心想，哦不，南希（Nancy）怎么了？因为我以为肯定出什么事了。我当时吓坏了。我以为她死了。然后他说，
has anyone heard from the emergency filling comedian? And I'm like, what the hell? And then he walks up to me and gives me my check and fires me. And it was so mortifying. Again, my first gig on the road, it's the holiday season. I walk out the front door and I'm like, oh no, I forgot my friends were coming that night.
有人听到紧急替补喜剧演员的消息吗？我心想，这到底是怎么回事？然后他走到我面前，把支票交给我，把我解雇了。这太让人难堪了。再说一遍，我的第一场巡演演出，正值假期。我走出门外，心想，哦不，我忘了我的朋友们今晚要来。
So my friends are in line to get into the show and they're like, woo, we're so excited. And I was like, I said, oh, I was just fired. My comedy was so bad, it caused an emergency. And so they're bringing in a fill-in comedian. Like they couldn't even stomach me for the rest, like that last night. So they said, let's all go meet at the Mercury Cafe. I'm like, okay, I go to get my friend's car and I drive off, hit an ice patch,
所以我的朋友们正在排队进场看演出，他们说，呜呼，我们太兴奋了。我当时就说，我说了，哦，我刚被解雇了。我的喜剧太烂了，以至于引发了一场紧急状况。所以他们正在带一个替补喜剧演员进来。就好像他们甚至连剩下的时间——最后一晚——都无法忍受我一样。所以他们说，我们去水星咖啡馆（Mercury Cafe）集合吧。我说，好吧，我去拿我朋友的车，然后我开车离开，撞上了一块冰，
spin out of control like in a cartoon. I'm in the car and I drive off, hit an ice patch, spin out of control like in a cartoon. I'm still in the parking lot of Witsen. And then the car stops and I'm of course pointed in the wrong direction. I'm mortified. I thought for sure it was going to be wrapped around a pole. And then I start laughing when I realize I lived through it because I immediately thought, what if I had used their car?
像动画片里一样失控打转。我坐在车里，开车离开，撞上了一块冰，像动画片里一样失控打转。我还在Witsen的停车场里。然后车停了下来，当然我车头朝向了错误的方向。我吓坏了。我当时确信车子会缠绕在电线杆上。然后我意识到自己活下来时开始笑，因为我立刻心想，如果我真的开了他们的车会怎么样？
Their car was a station wagon from the 70s that had clowns painted on it that said, follow me to Wits End Comedy Club. And if I had died in that moment, wrapped around a light bulb. After being fired. After being fired. Fuck.
他们的车是一辆70年代的旅行车，上面画着小丑，写着“跟着我到Wits End喜剧俱乐部”。如果我在那一刻死掉，缠绕在灯泡上。在被解雇之后。在被解雇之后。操。
Fired, so anyway, it's been a long road, but I'm almost 30 years in. Yeah, how did you stick with it with that kind of a start? Why didn't you say, yeah, fuck this, I'm going to start a different career? You know, I feel like standup is like if you're in an abusive relationship and you keep thinking, it was good once.
被解雇了，总之，这是一条漫长的路，但我快要干满30年了。是的，顶着这样的开局，你是怎么坚持下来的？你为什么没说，操，去他的，我要开始别的职业生涯了？你知道，我觉得单口喜剧就像是你身处一段虐心关系中，你总是觉得，它曾经好过。
I can get that feeling back, you know, because the first time I did standup, it was, I do think it went well enough. And then the second time I did not win the $100 in the competition I signed up for. Did you ever think about sending the charts from your number one comedy spot and sending it to the dude in Denver?
我能找回那种感觉，你知道的，因为我第一次演单口喜剧时，它，我确实觉得进展得足够顺利。然后第二次，我没有赢了我报名的比赛里的一百美元奖金。你有没有想过把你喜剧排名第一的图表发给丹佛那个家伙？
Well, he also died. Oh my God. Black Widow. Wow. Let's take it away from the pig. Out of the path of the pig. Yeah, yeah. I mean, what?
嗯，他也死了。哦天哪。黑寡妇。哇。让我们把话题从这只猪身上移开。避开这只猪的路线。是的，是的。我的意思是，什么？
Well, how about, do you think that your talent, your skill, your angle on all of this has progressively been arcing up? Like, has it continued to get better and better and better and better? My attitude? No, no, doing standup in your experience with it and like, are you, do you,
嗯，话说回来，你觉得你的才华、你的技巧、你对这一切的角度一直在稳步上升吗？就像，它有没有继续变得越来越好？我的态度？不，不，做单口喜剧以及你与它的经历，还有你是，你觉得，
My question is your attitude, yeah. Do you find that you're getting, is standup a thing that can be, I find that I'm getting hopefully a little bit better each year I continue on doing it over the hell I'm doing. Oh really? And do you, I think, over the hell I'm doing. Oh really? I think, I hope. Golfing, he's talking about golfing.
我的问题是你的态度，是的。你发现自己正在变得，单口喜剧是一件可以，我发现随着我继续做下去，每年我都在做这破事，希望自己能变得稍微好一点。哦真的吗？你觉得，我希望，随着我做这破事。哦真的吗？我想，我希望。打高尔夫球，他在谈论打高尔夫球。
Let's be clear, yeah it's golf. Is that something that you're still enjoying? Are you still ascendant in your life? Well you know, I finished my last tour and put out my standup special and my last tour really kind of ran me into the ground. And I'm working in Toronto right now. So this painting behind me is not mine.
坦白说，对，就是高尔夫。你现在还在享受这事儿吗？你的人生还在蒸蒸日上吗？你知道的，我结束了上一轮巡演，推出了我的单口喜剧专场，而上一轮巡演真的把我折腾得够呛。我现在正在多伦多工作。所以，我身后的这幅画不是我的。
That's not, I was gonna ask you about that. Listener, it's just a shot of basically Jesus' home. It's up there in the clouds somewhere. That's right. Go ahead. It's a nice hotel painting. But I've been working on new material when I have nights off here, and that's felt good. But I've had this building need and interest
那不是——我正想问你呢。听众朋友们，这基本上就是耶稣家的一个镜头。它就在那边的云层里某个地方。没错。请继续。这是一幅不错的酒店挂画。不过我在这里休息的晚上一直在创作新段子，感觉挺好的。但我一直有一种迫切的需求和兴趣
in doing a one-person show. But isn't that what you do? No, I want it to be a little more of a theme. Like a two act, three act structure. Like on Broadway. Yeah, yeah, sure. But like a more like, I love you, you're perfect, now change, like one of those ones that used to pass
去演一出独角戏。但你现在不就在做单口喜剧吗？不，我希望它更有主题性一点。比如有两幕、三幕的结构。就像百老汇那样。对，对，当然。但更像是那种，比如《我爱你，你太完美了，现在快改变》之类的，以前经常在
down sevens avenue. Yeah, do a little singing, dancing. Well, my Big Fat Greek reclining was a one woman show that turned into a movie because it was her story. So you mean something like that? Like a Spaulding Gray type of thing? Something, something like that. Or like a talk radio.
第七大道上演的剧目。对，加点唱歌跳舞。我的《我的盛大希腊婚礼》其实就是一出独角戏，后来因为讲的是她自己的故事才改编成电影的。所以你是说那种类型？就像斯波尔丁·格雷（Spaulding Gray）那种风格的东西？差不多，差不多。或者像那种谈话类广播。
Are we gonna keep going with? Yeah, keep guessing. More examples. So, I'll have a copy sent to you today. So then it is, so then there's a theme to it and it's a little bit more scripted or fully scripted. Well, I mean, my standup is scripted, but I do interact with the audience, right?
我们还要继续猜下去吗？对，继续猜。再举几个例子。所以，我今天会让人给你发一份副本。所以它是一个有主题的东西，剧本会更完整一些，或者说完全是写好的剧本。嗯，我的单口喜剧其实也是有剧本的，但我会和观众互动，对吧？
If an idea comes to me while I'm doing a show, I'll just go with that and just kind of explore it, because I don't sit down and write my comedy. I write on stage in front of a live audience. So I do it fully, you know, without a net type writing. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Do you do, I know you're up there in Toronto working, when you have free nights or whatever,
如果我在表演时突然冒出一个想法，我就会顺着那个思路往下走，稍微探索一下，因为我不会坐下来一字一句地写我的喜剧剧本。我是在现场观众面前通过上台表演来创作的。所以我完全是在进行一种，你知道的，没有安全网式的创作。对，对，对。你会去——我知道你在多伦多工作，当你空闲的晚上或者什么的，
do you still go and perform out like at clubs in Toronto? Are you doing that all the time? That's what I'm doing is there's a comedy club, yeah, out here in Toronto? Are you doing that all the time? That's what I'm doing. Is there's a comedy club out here in Toronto, Comedy Bar, and I've been doing shows, I don't know, two or three nights a week. Wow. You get a Comedy Bar car?
你还会去多伦多的俱乐部演出吗？你一直在这么做吗？我正在做的就是，多伦多这边有个喜剧俱乐部，对吧？多伦多这边？你一直在这么做吗？这就是我在做的。多伦多这里有个喜剧俱乐部叫Comedy Bar，我一直在那里演出，不知道，一周两三天吧。哇。他们会派一辆Comedy Bar的车接你吗？
They send you a car that says Comedy Bar? Follow me too. It says Zamboni. Comedy Bar? Just for a call back. Now you dabbled in, you do the acting as well, and then you dabbled in directing with Stephanie, your wife, right?
他们会派一辆写着Comedy Bar的车来接你吗？也跟着我。上面写着赞博尼（Zamboni）。Comedy Bar？这只是个现挂（Call back）。你现在也涉足表演，然后还跟你妻子斯蒂芬妮一起尝试了导演工作，对吧？
And we directed Sean Hayes. Yeah, good luck with that. Oh boy. Talk a little bit about that. Go ahead, stage is yours. We did, we made this decision last minute to hire him. We couldn't get anyone else in the role. I was the emergency actor.
我们还执导了肖恩·海耶斯（Sean Hayes）。祝你好运吧。噢天哪。稍微聊聊这个吧。请吧，舞台交给你了。我们做了这个决定，最后一分钟决定雇用他。我们找不到其他人选来演这个角色了。我是那个救场演员。
Who's the emergency actor? Nancy. The emergency else in the role. I was the emergency actor. The emergency fill-in actor. I was Nancy, yeah. That was super fun. I laughed so hard those two days. It was really fun. Is this a project we should plug? Yes, it's called MIOK, starring Dakota Johnson.
谁是救场演员？南希。那个救场——其他人选都不行。我是那个救场演员。那个救场替补演员。我演的是南希，对。那真的超级有趣。那两天我笑得肚子疼。真的很有趣。这是一个我们应该宣传一下的项目吗？是的，叫《MIOK》，由达科塔·约翰逊主演。
It was out a couple years ago, right? It came out this year. So thanks for being on top of that, promoting my hard work. You've been such a good friend. So what kind of part did Sean? Don't forget, he doesn't ask any questions, he has no idea, and he's not curious about your life.
那是几年前上映的吧？今年才上映的。所以谢谢你这么关注，帮我宣传我的心血。你一直是个这么好的朋友。那肖恩演的是个什么角色？别忘了，他什么问题都不问，什么都不知道，对你的生活也一点不好奇。
Yeah. Go ahead, Jason. No, I want to say something about the stand-up thing, though, because you know what always blows my mind? You want to change the subject from your casting? No, he has more bits that he used to do. Let's hear him. You know what blows my mind is when people get up there
好吧。请继续，杰森。不，关于单口喜剧的事，我还是想说点什么，因为你知道有什么总是让我觉得大开眼界吗？你想岔开话题，不聊你的选角了？不，他还有更多以前演过的段子。让我们听听。你知道让我大开眼界的是，当人们站在台上去时，
and they can just, how can you just talk? How do you have so much material that you don't, because I'm used to memorizing a script, right? And so, but there's nothing, and I know you've written it all, but just to like, if somebody says a topic, you can have the perfectly constructed joke about that thing.
他们怎么就能滔滔不绝地讲呢？你怎么能有那么多素材，而你又不用——因为我习惯了背剧本，对吧？所以，那里什么都没有，我知道你都写好了，但仅仅是——如果有人说出一个话题，你就能立刻对那个话题说出一个完美构思的笑话。
And you have it all at the bank of your head. But it's not all perfectly constructed. It's that I just try to leave my mind open outside of what I've already written or thought about. And then if something crosses my mind open outside of what I've already written or thought about. And then if something crosses my mind or somebody in the audience says something, I allow myself to go with that.
而且这些你都信手拈来。但并不是所有笑话都是完美构思出来的。而是我只是试着让自己的思维保持开放，不去局限于我之前已经写好或想过的东西。然后，如果有什幺想法划过我的脑海——不去局限于我之前已经写好或想过的东西。然后，如果有什幺想法划过我的脑海，或者观众席里有人说了什么，我允许自己顺着那个思路去发挥。
Whatever that is, yeah. Yeah. I got it. And explore and find what's funny about that. And now that you've had all of this tremendous success over the years, do people come up to you all the time and say, hey, I'm such a fan, can you just do, can you say that funny thing or like,
不管那是什么，对。对。我明白了。去探索并找出其中的笑点。既然你这些年来取得了如此巨大的成功，人们会不会经常走到你面前说，嘿，我是你的超级粉丝，你能——你能讲讲那个好笑的段子，或者像这样，
do they try to prompt you to perform for them? I would say the most common thing I get is that, no, no, people don't do that, but I did this like 15 minute bit about running into the pop star, Taylor Dane, I did this story years ago and I did it on This American Life. I ran into her so many times
他们会试着催促你为他们表演吗？我可以说我遇到最常见的情况是——不，不，人们不会那样做，但我曾经做过一个大约15分钟的段子，讲的是我偶遇流行歌手泰勒·戴恩（Taylor Dane），那是几年前我讲的一个故事，我在《This American Life》节目里讲过。我偶遇了她好多次，
and the first time I ran into her, I genuinely said, excuse me, I'm sorry to bother you, I just have to tell you I love your voice. And she was rude to me and she said, yeah, I don't do that anymore. And then turned and kept talking to somebody. And then I kept running into her and every time I saw her, I was like, oh my God, I'm going to go up and say the exact same thing
第一次偶遇她时，我是真心实意地对她说：打扰一下，很抱歉打扰你，我只是想告诉你我很喜欢你的声音。结果她对我很粗鲁，她说：“行了，我不再干那个了。”然后转过身去继续和别人聊天。后来我还是不断偶遇她，每次见到她，我都想，哦天哪，我要走过去，对她说出和我在那个派对上对她说的
I said to her at that party. And just for my sister, Taylor was a big 80s pop star. Just in case people don't know who Taylor is. Was your sister born after the 80s? The fuck are in case people don't know who Taylor Day was. Was your sister born after the 80s? The fuck are you doing? No, that was mine too, by the way. Was it really?
一模一样的话。为了我妹说一句，泰勒曾经是80年代的大红大紫的流行歌星。万一有人不知道泰勒是谁的话。你妹是80年代以后出生的吗？管他妈的万一有人不知道泰勒·戴恩是谁呢。你妹是80年代以后出生的吗？你到底在搞什么鬼？不，那也是我的词，顺便说一句。真的吗？
You didn't know who Taylor Day was? You don't know Taylor Day? Tell it to my heart. Tell it to my heart. Love will lead me back. Anyway, so you see her a bunch of times. So I see her out to dinner, I see her at cafes, I see her everywhere, and I just walk up
你不知道泰勒·戴恩是谁？你不知道泰勒·戴恩？《Tell it to my heart》（倾听我心）。《Tell it to my heart》。《Love will lead me back》（爱将带我回归）。不管怎样，所以你见了好多次。所以我看到她去吃晚饭，看到她在咖啡馆，到处都能看到她，然后我就走过去，
and I interrupted her every time and would say, hi, excuse me, I'm sorry to bother you. I just have to tell you, I love your voice. I love your voice. Yeah, every time. And it became this. Who the fuck are you? It became this experiment that I was doing.
每次都打断她，然后说，嗨，打扰一下，很抱歉打扰你。我只是想告诉你，我喜欢你的声音。我喜欢你的声音。对，每次都这样。这就变成了一个——你到底是谁啊？这就变成了一个我当时正在进行的实验。
Cause I was like. Did she know it was you every time at the show? No, no, she never registered. Never did. No way. Yeah, and. Did she die? But anyway. Never did. No way! Yeah, and, but anyway. Did she die? It's really funny.
因为我在想——每次演出她都知道是你吗？不，不，她从来没记住过。从来没有。绝不可能。对啊，而且——她死了吗？但不管怎样。从来没有。绝不可能！对啊，而且——但不管怎样。她死了吗？这真的太搞笑了。
Huh? Did she die? No, she's alive, and then we actually became friendly because of this, because word got out that, you know, I was doing this story, and then whatever. And I did this on This American Life. They did the story, and then invited Taylor Dane to that performance.
啊？她死了吗？不，她还活着，后来我们甚至因为这件事成了朋友，因为消息传出去了，你知道的，我在讲这个故事，然后巴拉巴拉。我在《This American Life》节目里讲了这个故事。他们播出了这个故事，然后邀请了泰勒·戴恩来参加那场演出。
And so I met her there. No way. But anyway, people come up to me all the time and say, excuse me, I'm sorry to bother you, but I just have to tell you, I love your voice. I love your voice. That's amazing. Wait, Tig, Tig, that's so good.
所以我就是在那里见到了她。不会吧。但不管怎样，人们经常走到我面前说，打扰一下，很抱歉打扰你，但我只是想告诉你，我喜欢你的声音。我喜欢你的声音。太绝了。等等，蒂格，蒂格，这太棒了。
I love that you did that. First of all, I love your commitment. That's amazing. Wait, Tig, that's so good. I love that you did that. First of all, I love your commitment to shit like that. You've told me umpteen stories of things that you do and one of my favorite, please tell us about some of the things you'll do at parties. Because these are my favorite. Party bits, sure. Party bits.
我太喜欢你这么做了。首先，我喜欢你的执着。这太惊人了。等等，蒂格，这太棒了。我太喜欢你这么做了。首先，我喜欢你对这种破事的执着。你跟我讲过无数次你做过的事情，其中我最喜欢的一个，请给我们讲讲你在派对上会做的一些事情。因为这些是我的最爱。派对小恶作剧，当然。派对小恶作剧。
Actually, you know a bit that I did on radio, morning radio when I first started doing standup, I'd have to go at six in the morning to some Fargo or something to do to promote my show. And I would always ask the radio host to please talk, as soon as I come on the show, please talk about how gorgeous I am. And just go on and on.
其实，你知道我以前在广播里做过的一个恶作剧吗？刚开始做单口喜剧的时候，早晨六点我得去法戈（Fargo）或者什么地方做早间广播，去宣传我的演出。我总是要求电台主持人一定要聊——我一上节目，就立刻聊我有多么天生丽质。然后一直夸个没完。
Like Howard Stern and certain people, just like you are beautiful. I mean, look at you. Because I thought, oh, maybe then I'll get people to the show, but also it really made me laugh to think of people showing up to see, this is years ago, and just seeing a disheveled, monotone lesbian on stage, you know, talking
就像霍华德·斯特恩（Howard Stern）和某些人那样，不停地说你太漂亮了。我是说，看看你。因为我想，哦，也许这样能帮我的演出拉到观众，但同时，一想到人们大老远跑来看——这是好几年前的事了——结果只看到一个蓬头垢面、毫无起伏的男同风女同站在台上，你知道的，还在聊着
about my cats. You're like, I didn't know I was going to an Indigo Girls concert. Hey, wait a second, but talk about the party bits. Oh, party bits. The fucking, oh God, I'm so jealous. I feel like you really liked this one, but my friend Henry Phillips, who is one of the funniest comedians, please look him up and watch everything he does.
我的猫，我就觉得太好笑了。你就像是在说，我不知道我是来听靛沟女孩（Indigo Girls）演唱会的。嘿，等一下，还是聊聊派对小恶作剧吧。哦，派对小恶作剧。他妈的，天哪，我太嫉妒了。我觉得你真的很喜欢这个，但我朋友亨利·菲利普斯（Henry Phillips），他是最有趣的喜剧演员之一，请大家去搜他并看他所有的作品。
He's so funny. Hi, Henry. And he has a couple of movies out, Punching Henry, Punching the Clown. I'm in one of the movies, but anyway, he and I do so many bits together. He's so good. And I used to live in Venice in California,
他太搞笑了。嗨，亨利。他有几部电影上映，《亨利重击》（Punching Henry）、《痛击小丑》（Punching the Clown）。其中一部电影里还有我呢，不管怎样，他和我有过很多这样的恶作剧。他太棒了。我以前住在加州的威尼斯（Venice），
and he was like, hey, I'm at a party near your house. He was like, I don't know any of these people. He was like, you got to come do some bits with me. And I was like, yeah, sure, I'll head over. I love the mischief of it. So I go meet him, and we're just loose at this party doing all these different bits that are truly for our own amusement,
然后他打电话说，嘿，我在你家附近的一个派对上。他说，这里的人我一个都不认识。他说，你得过来跟我一起搞点恶作剧。我说，行啊没问题，我这就过去。我喜欢那种恶作剧的恶趣味。于是我去找他，我们在那个派对上完全放飞自我，搞了各种各样的恶作剧，这些真的纯粹是为了我们自己开心，
which is what I do things for. And if people catch on or they enjoy it too, that's fine, but I love looking foolish. So I go in, I don't know anybody at this party except Henry. I go into the kitchen, there's like five people standing around, you know, leaning against the kitchen counter, having a drink, chatting. And it's a Saturday night, maybe 9.30,
这也是我做事情的初衷。如果别人能领会或者也觉得开心，那当然好，但我就是喜欢出洋相。所以我就走进去，在这个派对上除了亨利我谁都不认识。我走进厨房，大概有五个人站在那里，你知道的，靠着厨房操作台，喝着饮料，闲聊。那是周六晚上，大概9点半，
and I lean in and I just tap the wall and I go, hey guys, I'm going to be going to bed in like 10 minutes. I have no idea if the owner of the house is in there. I have no idea if the host is in the kitchen. I don't know who those people are. And then I go find Henry and I'm dying laughing. And I was like, oh my God, I just told five people in the kitchen I was going to bed in 10 minutes.
我凑过去，随手敲了敲墙说，嘿伙计们，我大概10分钟后就要去睡觉了。我根本不知道这房子的主人是不是在里面。我也不知道房东是不是在厨房里。我不认识那些人。然后我去找亨利，笑得肠子都快断了。我说，哦天哪，我刚刚跟厨房里的五个人说我10分钟后要去睡觉。
And he's like, oh my God. He said, there's like 200 people in the kitchen I was going to bed in 10 minutes. And he's like, oh my God, he said, there's like 200 people in the backyard. You have to go out on the deck and announce that. So I was like, no problem. And this is years ago, before I was like on TV regularly and whatever. And I walk out on the back deck, everyone's holding their solo cups and whatever.
然后他惊讶得不行。他说，后院里大概有200个人呢。你必须去露台上向大家宣布这个。于是我说，没问题。那是好几年前的事了，在我经常上电视或者什么的之前。我走到后院的露台上，每个人手里都拿着塑料红杯子之类的。
And I'm like, hey, everybody, just so you know, I'm going to be going to bed in like 10 minutes. And to me, I'm like, you know, it, I am, for all you know, I could be going home and going to bed in 10 minutes. That doesn't mean I own the house They're bad not yours. There's something about that that I've just always loved. I think it's the funny It's so that it's so funny funny. It reminds me. I used to always want to do this
我说，嘿，各位，告诉大家一声，我大概10分钟后就要去睡觉了。对我来说，我就觉得，你知道的，反正——就你们所知，我完全可能是在10分钟后回家睡觉。这并不代表这房子是我的。它们很烂，不是你的。不知为什么，我一直都很喜欢这种恶作剧。我觉得这太搞笑了。太搞笑了，真的太搞笑了。这让我想起。我以前一直想这么做，
But I never had the guts I wanted to drive around like Beverly Hills Bel Air like in a fancy car and pull up to gardeners as they're about to start on these big fucking estates and just go, roll my window down and go, I just spoke to the Mrs. She said you guys can take the day off fully paid and just start relieving gardening crews around Beverly Hills and Bel Air. And they're like, look at each other like, fully paid. Yeah, you got, she's, the Mrs. said, go ahead.
但我从来没有这个胆子。我想开着一辆豪车在贝弗利山（Beverly Hills）、贝莱尔（Bel Air）到处转悠，把车停在那些正准备开始打理这些豪华庄园的园丁旁边，摇下车窗然后说，我刚跟太太谈过了。她说你们今天可以带薪休假一天，然后就开始在贝弗利山和贝莱尔到处解除那些园林绿化队的职务。他们就会面面相觑，觉得，带薪休假？对，你听到了，太太说的，去吧。
She had a long night. You guys don't turn that shit on. Get out of here. I remember one time you texted me to, you said, I'm about to drive by your house. I want you to stand outside and look on your phone, but don't look at me as I drive by. And so I was like, okay, I'll do it.
她昨晚没睡好。你们别整那些破事了，滚吧。我记得有一次你发短信给我，你说，我马上要开车经过你家了。我要你站在外面看着手机，但当我开车经过时别看着我。所以我想，好吧，我照做。
And I stood by and I couldn't look up and you drove by and you said, hey Sean, hey Sean, and I didn't look up. That was the bit. That was the bit. I had a beat buried in my phone. I didn't quite understand it, but it made me laugh. You don't understand it? It was like performance art.
然后我就站在路边，不能抬头看，你开车经过时喊了，嘿，肖恩，嘿，肖恩，而我真的没有抬头。这就是那个恶作剧。这就是那个恶作剧。我脑子里埋着一个无厘头的节拍。我当时其实不太明白，但它让我笑得不行。你都不明白？这就像是行为艺术。
Yeah. God, that is so good. You know, you'd like this, my buddy, Pete Serifinowitz and all these English guys, they did this bit once. They'd go to a restaurant in London and they all learned beforehand. I like this, my buddy, Pete Sarifinowitz, and all these English guys, they did this bit once. They'd go to a restaurant in London, and they all learned beforehand.
天哪，太绝了。你知道的，你会喜欢这个，我的死党皮特·塞拉菲诺威茨（Pete Serafinowicz）和这帮英国佬，他们曾经搞过这样一个恶作剧。他们去伦敦的一家餐厅，大家提前都商量好了。我喜欢这个，我的死党皮特·塞拉菲诺威茨和这帮英国佬，他们曾经搞过这样一个恶作剧。他们去伦敦的一家餐厅，大家提前都商量好了。
They got together, they conspired, and they learned, and they sang, it was somebody's birthday. So they sang happy birthday, and then everybody at the table, like eight of them, launched into a second verse that they had written. So they start singing a second verse to happy birthday, and everybody in the restaurant starts looking at each other like, hey, what is this? verse that they had written. So they start singing a second verse to Happy Birthday and everybody in the restaurant starts looking at each other
他们聚在一起密谋，记下了歌词，然后唱了起来——正好有人过生日。所以他们唱了生日快乐歌，接着桌上的所有人，大概有八个吧，齐刷刷地唱起了他们自己写好的第二段歌词。于是他们开始唱生日快乐歌的第二段，餐厅里的所有人都开始面面相觑，心想，嘿，这是什么鬼？他们自己写好的第二段歌词。于是他们开始唱生日快乐歌的第二段，餐厅里的所有人都开始面面相觑，
like, hey, what is this? As if they've never done their second verse. That is so funny. How fucking funny is that? Oh my God. That's great. I am so jealous. I know.
心想，嘿，这是什么鬼？就好像他们从来没听过这第二段歌词似的。这太搞笑了。到底有多搞笑啊？天哪。太棒了。我太嫉妒了。我知道。
We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. Tate, what about the kids? You now have with your wife Stephanie, you have two little, the cutest boys ever. And they- Yes, Max and Finn, they're doing well. They are seven, eight.
我们马上回来。好了，欢迎回到节目中。蒂格，孩子们怎么样？你和妻子斯蒂芬妮现在有两个小家伙，最可爱的男孩子。他们——是的，马克斯（Max）和芬恩（Finn），他们挺好的。他们七岁、八岁了。
They are eight. They will be eight and a half this month. And huge into golf these days. Truly? They are so into golf. It is so. Come on. They're into baseball, basketball, they're on swim team. But yes, Sean, they have a sense of humor.
他们八岁了。他们这个月就八岁半了。而且现在超级迷高尔夫。真的吗？他们超级迷高尔夫。简直是——得了吧。他们喜欢棒球、篮球，还参加了游泳队。不过是的，肖恩，他们确实很有幽默感。
Funny, funny. My son Max, I think that, well I tell everyone he's bone dry and we don't know where he got that. And, but. Sure, sure. Who was it, was there a bone dry comedian that really kind of defined your comedic sensibility? Like was it like Steven Wright or somebody like that?
搞笑，太搞笑了。我的儿子马克斯，我觉得——好吧，我跟所有人都说他那种冷面幽默（bone dry）简直无师自通，我们都不知道他遗传了谁。而且，不过。确实，确实。那是谁，有没有哪个冷面幽默的喜剧演员真正塑造了你的喜剧审美？比如是史蒂芬·赖特（Steven Wright）还是类似的人？
I was really into Steven Wright. And I also really loved Paula Poundstone. I thought she was so great at writing jokes, telling stories, and also interacting with the audience. I felt like she could do everything and still feel that way. But yeah, my kids, they're like little, a friend of ours described them as like little Midwestern uncles. Because they're just, they have like a certain maturity
我以前非常迷史蒂芬·赖特。我也非常喜欢保拉·庞德斯通（Paula Poundstone）。我觉得她在写笑话、讲故事以及和观众互动方面简直太棒了。我觉得她无所不能，我现在依然这么觉得。不过话说回来，我的孩子们，他们就像是小——我们的一个朋友形容他们就像“中西部的小叔叔”。因为他们身上有一种特有的成熟稳重，
about them and my son Max, one of my favorite things that he said when he was four, Stephanie and I were sitting on the couch with Max, Finn, her dad and our three cats. And Max got up when he was four, just got off the couch and he said, I'm getting the hell out of here. All these damn cats. I walked out of the room.
而且我儿子马克斯，他四岁时说过的话里我最喜欢的一句是：当时斯蒂芬妮和我正和马克斯、芬恩、她爸爸以及我们三只猫坐在沙发上。马克斯四岁的时候站了起来，从沙发上下来，然后说：“老子要滚蛋了。这群该死的猫。”然后就走出了房间。
I was like, I like your style, kid. No way. That is so funny. Yeah, they're the best. Never dogs for you? No, I've had dogs. I've had a couple of dogs in my life, but we call our house Kitty City.
我当时就想：我喜欢你的风格，小家伙。不会吧。太搞笑了。对啊，他们最棒了。你从来不养狗吗？不，我养过狗。我生命中养过几只狗，但我们管我们的家叫“猫咪之城”。
Yeah, and do you like that the cats just sort of, they take care of themselves, and they don't bother you, you don't bother them? Yes, I like that in a person. Yeah, a dog needs shit, right? A cat needs nothing. I mean, but I do love an excited dog that's just about to have a stroke.
对，你是不是很喜欢猫那种会照顾自己、不打扰你、你也不打扰它们的生活方式？对，我也希望人能这样。对啊，狗要拉撒对吧？猫什么都不需要。不过说实话，我也挺喜欢那种兴奋得快要中风的狗的。
They're so excited to see you. They get the zoomies. Yeah. Now Stephanie, you really make Stephanie laugh too, which is great. You guys laugh a lot. Yeah, I love Stephanie. Stephanie really makes me laugh a lot.
它们看到你时兴奋得不得了。它们会开始疯狂转圈（zoomies）。现在，斯蒂芬妮，你总是能把斯蒂芬妮逗笑，这太棒了。你们经常笑个不停。对，我爱斯蒂芬妮。斯蒂芬妮经常把我逗得哈哈大笑。
Yeah, and she's really funny too. She's super funny. She's so funny and she's in love with Will. I'm in love with Jason and we don't know where Sean fits into this equation. Sean was with the kiddies. I love Stephanie. Yeah.
对，而且她其实也很有趣。她超级有趣。她太有趣了，而且她深爱着威利。我深爱着杰森，而我们不知道肖恩在这个等式里算怎么回事。肖恩跟小家伙们在一块儿。我爱斯蒂芬妮。对。
I love Stephanie. Yeah. I love Stephanie. Is there a meet cute there you want to share with us? Yeah. We met on the movie, Lake Bell's movie called In A World. The Great Lake Bell. Yeah, and I was deathly ill.
我爱斯蒂芬妮。对。你们之间有什么“一见钟情”的浪漫邂逅想跟我们分享吗？有的。我们在湖铃（Lake Bell）导演的电影里认识的，那部电影叫《内部世界》（In A World）。伟大的湖铃。对，当时我病得要死。
I didn't know I had three deadly diseases at one time. And then I collapsed, went away and dealt with. Wait, was this the cancer? It was cancer, pneumonia, and this intestinal disease called C. diff. I had it all three at once. Christ. So I go away, and I was in a relationship.
我当时不知道自己同时得了三种致命疾病。然后我晕倒了，去接受治疗并挺了过来。等等，这是癌症吗？是癌症、肺炎，还有一种叫难辨梭状芽胞杆菌（C. diff）的肠道疾病。我当时三种病并发。天呐。所以我去治病了，当时我还在谈恋爱。
Stephanie had never dated a woman. We really enjoyed each other on set, but I wasn't thinking I was into her romantically, and she wasn't thinking that about me. So I collapse, I go away. Six months later, I resurface in the world, and the movie's going to Sundance. And we exchanged numbers and I told her,
斯蒂芬妮以前从没和女人约会过。我们在片场合作得非常愉快，但我当时并没有对她产生浪漫的心思，她对我也没有。所以我晕倒了，去治病了。六个月后，我又回到了现实世界，电影要去圣丹斯电影节了。我们交换了电话号码，我告诉她，
I said, you know, I'm not the biggest texter. And I told her about this girl that texted me incessantly after coffee and that she texted that night, she said, sweet dreams, the girl I had gone out with. And not that I thought Stephanie was into me, but I was just giving her the example that I'm not great at this. And that night Stephanie texted me sweet dreams.
我说，你知道的，我不是个爱发短信的人。我还跟她提起过一个女孩，在喝完咖啡后不停地给我发短信，而那天晚上那个女孩发短信说：“做个好梦”，这就是我之前出去约会过的那个女孩。我倒不是觉得斯蒂芬妮对我有意思，我只是举个例子告诉她我在这方面不太在行。结果那天晚上斯蒂芬妮给我发短信说：“做个好梦”。
And I was like, oh, that is hilarious. And then we start texting and it's kind of building and I'm thinking, oh, I'm really into her. And she had invited me, I was writing my book at the time, she invited me to come meet her and her friends at La Puebel in Los Angeles. And I thought, oh my God, it's 11 o'clock, I haven't showered, I'm wearing this big wool,
当时我就想：哦，这太搞笑了吧。然后我们开始发短信，感情有点在升温，我在想，哦，我是真的对她有点动心了。当时我正在写我的书，她邀请我和她的朋友们在洛杉矶的La Puebel见面。我想，哦天哪，已经11点了，我还没洗澡，身上穿着这件厚厚的羊毛衫，
Canadian wool sweater with an eagle on my back, I can't go meet her. And then I thought, oh, well, she's not even into me, so who cares what I look like. And it happened to be Valentine's Day. And so she's sitting at this table. Happened to be. But truly, she wasn't into women.
加拿大羊毛衫，背后还绣着一只老鹰，我怎么能去见她。然后我又转念一想，哦，反正她又对我没意思，那我穿成什么样谁在乎呢。那天刚好是情人节。于是她坐在那张桌子旁。刚好是。但说真的，她对女人根本没兴趣。
And so she's at this table with friends. I walk into the bar, she is wearing a dark blue she's at this table with friends. so I can take a picture of you. We go to hug each other and we start making out immediately when we touch each other. And then, so we end up making out that night and then she writes me a five million page email the next day, I get it, that's telling me how much she loves hanging out with me,
所以她和朋友们坐在桌子旁。我走进酒吧，她穿着一件深蓝色——她正和朋友们坐在桌子旁——这样我就可以给你拍张照了。我们走过去拥抱对方，刚一接触就立刻开始热吻起来。然后，那天晚上我们俩就在一起疯狂热吻，接着第二天她给我写了一封五百万字长的电子邮件，我懂的，
how funny she thinks I am, she's not gay, but that she wants to be friend, like goes, I can't tell you how long this email was. I'm reading this going, ah, because I realized I do like her, you know? But I thought, I can't chase her because she's not into it. So I wrote back, okay, Dyke. And, okay, dyke. And that's the only thing I wrote.
里面倾诉了她有多么喜欢跟我待在一起，她觉得我有多么幽默，她自己虽然不是同性恋，但她想和我做朋友——总之，我简直无法形容这封邮件有多长。我一边读一边想：“啊？”，因为我意识到我是真的喜欢她，你知道吗？但我想，我不能去追求她，因为她对女人没感觉。所以我回信写道：“好吧，同性恋（Dyke）。”然后，好吧，同性恋。这就是我回的全部内容。
And then she said when she got that response, she just thought, okay, I like this person. And so now. Yeah, that's great. And then so, I mean, at the, you know, however you're comfortable relaying this, if there's any further in the story you're willing to go, how does that, do you guys just start seeing each other
然后她说当她收到这条回复时，她脑子里只闪过一个念头：好吧，我挺喜欢这个人的。所以现在——对，太棒了。那么，在——用你觉得舒服的方式，如果你愿意继续讲这个故事的话，接下来会怎么样？你们俩就这么开始交往
for a while, because you want to respect her sexuality, but you want to continue seeing her, but you also don't want to work on flipping her, or how does that go? What happens? Well so. It's a good question. I just don't like how do you protect your own heart?
了一段时间吗？因为你想尊重她的性取向，但又想继续跟她见面，但你又不想试图去“掰弯”她，这到底是怎么发展的？后来怎么了？嗯，所以——这是一个很好的问题。我只是在想，你该如何保护自己的内心呢？
And like you know. I go to work on flipping her. I put on my hard hat. I didn't know that she had, that OK, I didn't know OK Dyke made the impression that it did, I just thought I need to be lighthearted, let this go and just see her as a friend down the road. But I knew it was gonna take me a beat.
而且你知道的——我去努力把她“掰弯”。我戴上了我的安全帽。我当时并不知道——好吧，我当时不知道那句“好吧，同性恋”会产生那样的效果，我当时只是觉得我需要轻松一点，顺其自然，以后把她当普通朋友看待就行了。但我知道这需要我花点时间来消化。
So I told her, I said, I get it, you know, like when we talked again, I said, I just need some space and then I'll be able to see you as a friend and everything's fine. And so I went to Montreal and was doing shows there and she reached out to me like a few weeks later and she said, I'd like to see you when you get home. And I said to my friend who was there with me
所以我告诉她，我说，我懂的，你知道的，当我们再次交谈时，我说，我只是需要一点空间，然后我就能把你当朋友看待了，一切都会好起来的。于是我去了蒙特利尔并在那里演出，几周后她联系了我，她说：“等你回家了我想见见你。”我对当时陪着我的朋友说，
and I was like, why does she want it? What? And he was like, cause she likes you. And I was like, no, no, no, I know, but she told me she doesn't want it. He was like, what do you think? She And I was like, no, no, no, I know, but she told me she doesn't want, he was like, what do you think? She's like, oh, I want to see you again so I can tell you for sure I don't like you.
我说：“她想干嘛？什么情况？”他却说：“因为她喜欢你呀。”我说：“不，不，不，我懂，但她亲口告诉我她不想——”他却说：“你觉得呢？”她说——哦，我想再见你一面，好亲口告诉你我其实不喜欢你。
And I was like, I don't know, maybe. And then she came over. You had multiple friends that were females that weren't gay, right? You had multiple friends that were females that weren't gay, so you were thinking, maybe this is just another one of those perhaps. Yeah, I just didn't know what to think.
而我想：我不知道，也许吧。然后她就过来了。你以前有过好几个不是同性恋的女性朋友，对吧？你以前有过好几个不是同性恋的女性朋友，所以你当时在想，也许这次又是那种情况之一吧？对，我当时真的不知道该作何感想。
But I got back to LA and she came over and she's just a very, she's a very confident, comfortable person and she's very straightforward. And it's what I realized I'm so into about her. And so she sat down on my couch and she just turned to me and said I realized that I want to be with you and I was like oh what do you mean? And she said like I want to be with you. I don't want to I'm not saying I want to see how it goes or check things out I want to be with you. And I was like, what?
但我回到洛杉矶后，她过来了，她是一个非常自信、非常随性的人，而且说话非常直来直去。我发现这正是我最迷恋她的地方。于是她坐在我的沙发上，转过身对我说：“我意识到我想和你在一起。”我当时就惊了：“啊？你什么意思？”她说：“我是说我想和你在一起。我不是说想看看情况发展或者试着交往，我是真的想和你在一起。”当时我就懵了：什么？
I was so, I was so. Did you still have the eagle jacket on or? I did. You still hadn't showered. You still hadn't showered. We took our eagle jackets off and we got down to it. And it was just pure, it wasn't about declaring as a label or anything,
我当时太——我整个人都——你当时还穿着那件老鹰夹克吗？穿着呢。你还没洗澡呢。你还没洗澡呢。我们脱下了老鹰夹克，然后直奔主题。那种感觉纯粹无比，无关乎给自己贴什么标签或宣告什么身份，
I was just like, all I know is I just really wanna be with you, whatever that is, it is. And yeah, that's great. Yeah, and we make each other laugh a lot. I love that, I love her so much. And I love you so much. And I remember one time you were doing your live show and you wanted me as a guest and it was at the.
我当时只知道：我只明白一件事，我就是真的很想跟你在一起，不管这算什么关系，它就是这样。对，太棒了。对，而且我们总是能把对方逗得哈哈大笑。我太喜欢这样了，我好爱她。我也好爱你们。我还记得有一次你在做你的现场演出，你想让我当嘉宾，那是在——
Largo. Largo, at Largo. And so we had such a good time and we laughed really hard. And then the next day, literally the next day. Next morning. I go, yeah, the next morning I go to Le Pan, this restaurant on Larchmont and you walk in and we both have the exact same outfit on that we had
Largo。Largo剧场，在Largo。我们当时玩得太开心了，笑得撕心裂肺。然后第二天，简直就是第二天——第二天早上。我说，对，第二天早上我去Le Pain，那是Larchmont街上的一家餐厅，你一走进去，我们俩身上穿着的竟然是完全一模一样的衣服——
that we were on stage in. No, wow. We both slept in those clothes and then woke up thinking, well, it's early. It's, I just want an egg. I want a couple eggs and I'm going to go home and shower and change. You're across the city.
就是我们在台上穿的那套。天哪，不会吧。我们俩都穿着那身衣服睡了觉，然后醒来心想，好吧，时间还早。我只是想吃个鸡蛋。我想吃几个鸡蛋，然后回家洗澡换衣服。你在城市的另一头——
No one from the show is going to be there. Yeah. Do you remember that? Except we live close to each other and dress alike. Yeah, exactly. Oh, and you know what I have to say? Also, Stephanie directed my latest standup special. Oh no way.
秀场的其他人根本不可能在那儿。对。你还记得吗？除了我们俩住得很近而且品味一样。对，没错。哦，你知道我必须说的是什么吗？还有，斯蒂芬妮执导了我的最新单口喜剧专场。哦，不会吧。
And was nominated for NEMI, and so was the editor, and so was everyone else, except me. I was the problem. Oh no. Oh really? Oh no. Now wait, what is the name of that one? Is that one Hello Again?
而且获得了艾美奖（NEMI）提名，剪辑师也是，其他所有人都获得了提名，除了我。我才是那个有问题的人。哦不。哦真的吗？哦不。等一下，那个专场叫什么名字来着？是叫《Hello Again》吗？
That is Hello Again, yeah. Very, very nice. Very nice. Are you in Toronto doing standup or movie? Standup. Show. I'm doing a show, yeah. I'm doing Star Trek.
对，就是《Hello Again》。非常非常棒。太棒了。你在多伦多是在演单口喜剧还是拍电影？单口喜剧。演出。我在演一个剧，对。我在演《星际迷航》。
I know what she's doing because I have asked her. I'm doing Star Trek with Holly Hunter and Paul Giamatti. Yeah. Oh great. Wow, do they have to wear the alien makeup? Paul, yes. Holly, no. Are they lesbians in space too? I have to ask.
我知道她在做什么，因为我问过她。我在和霍莉·亨特（Holly Hunter）以及保罗·吉亚玛提（Paul Giamatti）一起拍《星际迷航》。哦，太棒了。哇，他们得化那种外星人妆吗？保罗要，霍莉不用。他们在太空里也是同性恋吗？我得问问。
Just for full... It's called Starfleet Academy, lesbians in space. That's the new series. We don't know, I don't know Holly, but we love Paul Giamatti. He's just a gem. He's a gem, gem, gem. Yeah, he is. Yeah, and Holly's great too.
为了了解全貌……这剧叫《星际学院》（Starfleet Academy），讲的是太空里的同性恋。这是新剧。我们不知道——我不认识霍莉，但我们超爱保罗·吉亚玛提。他简直就是个宝藏。他绝对是个无价之宝。对，确实。对，霍莉也很棒。
I'm sure. Obviously a real talent. And then I'm thrown in the mix. Don't you dare. Don't you dare. Don't you dare. Take Notaro as a gem. But I do have, I mean, close to lesbians.
我确信。显然是个真正的天才。然后我就被扔进这个阵容里了。你敢！你敢这么说！你敢！蒂格·诺塔罗（Tig Notaro）是个宝藏。但我确实有——我是说，跟同性恋差不多。
Well, it's across the spectrum, but my podcast, Handsome, is right here on planet Earth. It's like my fourth podcast. I don't know if you know, I've been podcasting for a long time, you guys. And how are you loving it? Are you loving it? You're still loving it.
好吧，这涵盖了各种各样的人群，但我的播客《Handsome》就在地球上播出。这就像是我的第四个播客。我不知道你们知不知道，我做播客已经很久了，伙计们。你有多喜欢它？你喜欢吗？你还是很喜欢。
I really enjoy podcasting. Oh my gosh, yeah. I was so baffled by it in the early days. I think I started in like, I don't know, 2006 or something. I have no idea. But I do enjoy it. It's such a different way to be comedic and tell stories. Yeah, and you can do it inside the comfort
我真的很享受做播客。天哪，是的。在早期的时候我被它彻底搞糊涂了。我想我大概是在2006年左右开始做的吧？我记不清了。但我真的很享受。这是一种非常不同的展现喜剧和讲故事的方式。对，而且你可以在舒适的
of an air-conditioned room. In the comfort of an air-conditioned or heated furnished apartment in Toronto. Yeah, yeah. Up there with the Jesus painting behind you. Do you want, I'll text her real quick, guaranteed she's available. Do you want to have lunch with my mom today?
空调房里完成它。在多伦多开着空调或暖气的精装修公寓里享受舒适。对，对。头上顶着身后那幅耶稣像。你想不想——我马上给她发个短信，保证她有空。你今天想跟我妈一起吃午饭吗？
I would love to. Would you? She's close. She's a character, she's a lot of fun. She'll keep you on your toes. I'll hook up the lunch. Okay, I'm gonna hook it up. Take hurry home and get back to our Sunday rhythm, please.
我非常愿意。真的吗？她就在附近。她很有个性，非常有意思。她会让你时刻保持精神紧绷。我来安排这顿午餐。行，我来安排。蒂格，快点回家，回到我们周日的日常节奏里来吧，求你了。
Yeah, we miss you. We miss you. I have missed you dearly. We would love to see you. When does this come out? Today, it's on right now. You gotta tell your family. Yeah.
对，我们想你了。我们太想你了。我真的非常想念你们。我们很想见到你。这期节目什么时候播出？今天，现在就在播。你得告诉你的家人。对。
I'm gonna tell all my dead parents. But hurry home so we can hang out again. There's a better chance of them listening than if Sean's dad listening. But at that point. Yeah. Wait, how can I naturally mention, cause I wanted to naturally mention something
我要告诉所有我死去的双亲。但快点回家，这样我们才能一起玩。比起肖恩的爸爸在听，她们听到的几率还更大一点。但到了那个时候——对。等等，我怎么才能自然地提起——因为我本来想自然地提起一件事，
and I didn't naturally mention it. You're doing it. I have a documentary that just got accepted to Sundance. You ready for this? Fantastic. And weren't you working on a documentary for a while? Yeah, I was gonna get to that, Will. I've got a bunch of questions here.
结果我没能自然地提起来。你现在不就在提嘛。我有一部纪录片刚刚被圣丹斯电影节接受了。你们准备好了吗？太棒了。你不是筹备一部纪录片很久了吗？对，我正要说到这儿，威利。我这里有一堆问题呢。
Jason, you didn't even know about it. Thank you for asking, Will. Yes, I have been working on a documentary. And I had called their incredible filmmakers. They did the Pamela documentary and the Dr. Ruth documentary, Serena Williams, all this. But I was like, I can't sell you on this person. You have to do a deep dive, not even that deep on Andrea Gibson. And they called me three days later,
杰森，你甚至都不知道这事。谢谢你问起，威利。是的，我一直在制作一部纪录片。我当时找了那些了不起的电影制作人。他们制作过《帕特丽夏·阿奎莱拉》（Pamela）纪录片、《鲁斯博士》（Dr. Ruth）纪录片、塞雷娜·威廉姆斯（Serena Williams）等等。但我当时对他们说：我没办法把这个人向你们推销出去。你们必须深入了解——甚至不需要那么深入——安德里亚·吉布森（Andrea Gibson）。结果他们三天后给我打电话，
and they were like, we're in, and they got on a plane, flew to Boulder, Colorado, and started filming. When does it come out? Well, it's gonna be at Sundance. Sundance, okay. It's in January, right? It's in January.
说：“我们接了。”然后他们直接买机票飞到科罗拉多州博尔德市开始拍摄。什么时候上映？嗯，它会在圣丹斯电影节上映。圣丹斯，好的。是在一月对吧？是在一月。
But Andrea is a brilliant poet, just a brilliant poet, mind-blowing. Yeah, what's it called, the documentary? I believe right now it's Come See Me in the Good Light. You keep shifting, the title's kind of shifting a little bit as we get closer to finish. Well, I mean, that's the last I've heard, is that's the working title,
但安德里亚是一位才华横溢的诗人，简直是才华横溢，令人惊叹。对了，这部纪录片叫什么名字？如果我没记错的话，目前叫《在好光线里来看我》（Come See Me in the Good Light）。随着我们越来越接近完成，片名稍微有点变动。好吧，我是说，这是我听到的最新消息，暂定片名是
is Come See Me in the Good Light, but it's a phenomenal documentary about a phenomenal person. Sorry, mention Andrea's full name again for the... Andrea Gibson. Andrea Gibson. Andrea Gibson. Written eight books. Oh, amazing. Wow. Incredible book. I'll check her out online.
《在好光线里来看我》，但这是一部关于一个非凡之人的非凡纪录片。抱歉，请再提一下安德里亚的全名——安德里亚·吉布森。安德里亚·吉布森。安德里亚·吉布森。写过八本书。哦，太惊人了。哇。不可思议的书。我要去网上搜来看看。
Amazing. These guys will love the books. Yeah, you have the Zara Nadeo version in those pictures. These love the books. Yeah, does there an audio version in those pictures? Now, are you going to go to Sundance? Okay, good. I'm going to go to Sundance and yeah, going to Sundance. Well, good luck with it. Congratulations on that.
太棒了。这几位一定会喜欢这些书的。对，你在那些照片里看过有声书版本吗？这些家伙一定会喜欢这些书的。对，你在那些照片里看过有声书版本吗？那你这次要去圣丹斯吗？好吧，太好了。我要去圣丹斯，对，去圣丹斯。好吧，祝你好运。恭喜你。
Finish strong there in Toronto and get your ass back home here. Send our love to Stephanie, who we also miss. And all of my love to your families. And I'll see you at Sunday Fun Day, anytime I'm home. Very soon. Wonderful. Very soon.
在多伦多完美收官，然后赶紧屁颠屁颠滚回老家来。代我们向斯蒂芬妮问好，我们也同样想念她。把我的爱带给你们所有的家人。只要我在家，随时周日狂欢日见。非常快。太棒了。非常快。
All right, love you. Thank you for doing this. Enjoy the rest of your day and stay warm up there. Well, truly, thanks for having me. Of course. Love you all dearly. Thank you for doing this. Enjoy the rest of your day and stay warm up there. Well, truly, thanks for having me. Of course. Love you all dearly. Love you too. Love you too.
好了，爱你们。谢谢你们录制这期。享受你们剩下的一天，在多伦多注意保暖。真的，谢谢你们邀请我。当然。深深地爱着你们所有。谢谢你们录制这期。享受你们剩下的一天，在多伦多注意保暖。真的，谢谢你们邀请我。当然。深深地爱着你们所有。我也爱你们。我也爱你们。
Love you, honey. That was awesome. Bye. Bye. Guys, that was Tig Notaro. Yeah. That was Tig Notaro. Okay, Tig Notaro, spelled T-I-G.
爱你，亲爱的。太棒了。拜拜。拜拜。伙计们，刚才那是蒂格·诺塔罗。对。刚才那是蒂格·诺塔罗。好的，蒂格·诺塔罗，拼写是T-I-G。
Yep. That was such a funny story about her name, good cord. About the pig teat. You know, pigs do have teets. And you can get, did you know you can get milk from a pig? That there's pig milk? That there's certain countries they drink pig milk? Oh God, I'll try it.
没错。关于她名字里那个好笑的故事，好配方（good cord）。关于母猪的乳头。你知道的，猪确实有乳头。你可以——你知道你可以从母猪身上挤出奶吗？有猪奶这东西？有些国家的人会喝猪奶？天哪，我想尝尝。
Did you know that? Will, did you know that? No, I don't know what you're talking about, man. Pig milk. Okay. Pig milk. Okay. And people drink pig milk, they put it in cream, yeah.
你知道这个吗？威利，你知道吗？不，我不知道你在说什么，老兄。猪奶。好吧。猪奶。好吧。而且人们会喝猪奶，他们把它做成奶精，对。
You knew that though. You put it in cereal? I'll put it in cereal. I didn't know it, no. I actually drink pig milk, they put it in cream. You knew that though. You put it in cereal? I'll put it in cereal. I didn't know it, no. I actually, I feel worse for now. It's not true, I was hoping you would say, yeah, of course I fucking knew that. You fucking.
不过你其实是知道的。你把它倒进麦片里？我会倒进麦片里。我其实不知道，真的。我甚至感觉更糟糕了。这不是真的，我本来希望你会说：“对，我他妈的当然知道这事。”你个混蛋。
How great is Tic? Tic, we've known for, I've known Tic for a long, long, long, long time. She's always been so funny and so unique, like there's nobody like her. No. Yeah, and I just love, because I usually end up sitting next to her at Sunday.
蒂格有多棒？蒂格，我们认识——我认识蒂格很长、很长、很长、很长时间了。她一直都那么有趣，那么独特，没有人能取代她。没有。对啊，我特别喜欢，因为我通常最后都会坐在她旁边，在周日聚会上。
And I just, I love, I just drink it all up. I love her. I love every minute with her. Yeah. So Willie, I say you call your mom and- I might do it. I would have lunch with your mother in a heartbeat if I was in trouble.
而且我就是喜欢——我全盘接受。我爱她。和她在一起的每一分钟我都爱。所以威利，我建议你给你妈打个电话——我可能会打。如果我在附近，我恨不得马上跟你妈一起吃午饭。
Oh my God, I would too. I would love, when is she gonna come down here? I wanna talk to her. You know what else I'd like to do? I'd like to go to your childhood home. I'd like to see your bedroom, which I bet is still pretty much intact. Yeah, sure. No, no, no, no, no.
天哪，我也想。我很想——她什么时候来这边？我想跟她聊聊。你知道我还想做什么吗？我想去你童年住过的房子看看。我想看看你的卧室，我敢打赌那里基本上还是原封不动的老样子。当然。不，不，不，不。
I've moved a few times since, yeah. What would we see on your boyhood wall when you were growing up in the house there? Were there like posters of hockey players? Like you know, 12, 13, 14? Okay, well these are very, so like 11, from the time I was like six to 11, I had a map of the world.
从那以后我搬过好几次家了，对。我们在你小时候住的那个房子的男孩卧室墙上会看到什么呢？会不会贴满了冰球运动员的海报？就像你12、13、14岁的时候那样？好吧，这些其实很——大概从我6岁到11岁的时候，我贴了一张世界地图。
This is true, huge map of the world. And then underneath on the sort of the legend underneath, it had all the countries and it just had, listen, just basic info about every country. Capital, the size, it's sort of square mileage, population, et cetera, for every country in the world. So I had that. Wow.
确实如此，一张巨大的世界地图。然后在下面，也就是底部的图例说明里，列出了所有的国家，上面写着——听着，就是关于每个国家的基 本信息。首都、面积，也就是平方英里数、人口等等，世界上每个国家都有。所以我当时有这个。哇。
And then when I was a teenager, I ended up having like, I went to boarding school, as you know, for a few years, and then I came back and I had a Smiths poster on my wall. Yeah, sure. I had a big, the world won't listen in, an Morrissey poster. Yeah, the best. Were you kind of like a mod?
然后当我十几岁的时候，我最终——如你所知，我去寄宿学校呆了几年，然后我回来了，我的墙上贴着一张史密斯乐队的海报。是的，没错。我有一张很大的、专辑《The World Won't Listen》的海报，还有一张莫里西的海报。是的，最棒的。你有点像摩德族（Mod）吗？
Did you ever wear like eyeliner? No, no, no, no, but I wore like tapered, like green sort of Dickies type pants. I wore a lot of that. And I wore... Doc Martens? Doc Martens brogues. What are brogues?
你化过眼线吗？不，不，不，不，但我穿那种锥形裤，比如绿色狄奇（Dickies）那类裤子。我穿了很多那种。我还穿了……马丁靴？马丁靴布洛克鞋。什么是布洛克鞋？
Like shoes, right? Like wingtips sort of like, you know what I mean? I got it. Like ducky from Pretty in Pink. Yeah, but I never, but yeah, but like, but never, I wasn't a mod in that sense. But I, yeah, but... You kept it tasteful, sure.
就像鞋子，对吧？有点像翼尖鞋，你知道我的意思吗？我懂了。就像电影《粉红佳人》里的达基（Ducky）。对，但我从来没——对，但就像，但从来没有，我不是那种意义上的摩德族。但我，是的，但……你保持了高雅的品味，当然。
Yeah, of course. You keep it timeless, but I, yeah. You kept it tasteful, sure. Yeah, of course. You keep it timeless, that's the key. Oh, sorry. Okay, 12 or 13. Did you have posters of yourself on your wall? Because you were in like Tiger Beat and 16 and all that shit. All the different hairstyles, because there's different sweater in each one, you know.
是的，当然。你保持了永不过时的风格，但我，是的。你保持了高雅的品味，当然。是的，当然。你保持了永不过时的风格，这才是关键。哦，抱歉。好的，12岁或13岁。你的墙上有自己的海报吗？因为你上过《Tiger Beat》和《16》杂志以及诸如此类的烂玩意儿。各种不同的发型，因为每一本里的毛衣都不一样，你知道的。
Yeah, yeah. God, I wish it revealed that Sean had a post review in his room, it would be the best thing. That would be the greatest reveal. I had a lot. I think we said this when Rashida was on the show. I had a life-size poster of Quincy Jones on my wall. Did you really?
对，对。天哪，我真希望这能显示出肖恩的房间里贴着他自己的海报，那将是最棒的事。那将是最伟大的揭秘。我有很多。我想当希达上节目时我们说过这个。我的墙上有一张昆西·琼斯的等身海报。真的吗？
Oh, wow. That my dad just put up there for me, and I just never took it down. That weird. You never took it down? Yeah. All I had was Michael Jackson posters everywhere. Did you really? When I was a kid, and my favorite one was probably
哦，哇。那是我的爸爸帮我贴在那里的，而我从来没有把它撕下来。真奇怪。你从来没撕下来过？对。我到处贴的都是迈克尔·杰克逊的海报。真的吗？当我还是个孩子的时候，我最喜欢的可能
By-lee-gee. Oh my God, by-lee-gee. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarff. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拜里吉。天哪，拜里吉。聪明。无。聪明。无。《Smartless》由本尼特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿尔马夫100%有机且纯手工打造。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。